e
e e
little bit up to hearing on house Cod
167 and here from representative spear
who will fill out a pink card afterwards
can you see me over
[Music]
this uh my name is Carrie spear I
represent uh Nash Ward three and
representative Thomas couldn't be here
today because she's introducing seven
other bills so she asked me to
introduced this
bill I'm going to read essentially what
she wrote as
her uh comments for this bill but I have
comments of my own to add to it as
well this bill is specifically set up to
uh well you know let me start that again
the committee has worked for a whole
year on Banning certain past products to
come into at at consumer products uh in
the to come into the state and we are uh
the bill that passes
1649 and we did a lot of work on that
and and I I I think we understand what
the problem is with PFS this bill is
specifically geared to
ban uh p
in ski board and boat wax a very simple
it's a very simple idea and the I and
the reason why I say it's simple is that
it's a single product it's easy to it's
very easy to ban and all the states
around us have already banned it banned
the those versions with
pasas now the in the FIS which stands
for the international ski Federation
which is the governing body for the
inter ational skiing and snowboarding
have already had banned it in 1921 so
this is not new all over Europe they
don't use it the Olympics don't use it
it's it's already been
done for reasons that I'm not clear on
they're still selling it out there and
every company that
makes the
wax makes a
past free less free thank you a preast
free version now my husband uh races
both nationally and locally nobody on
the racing teams in the United
States at least at the national level
use wax with PS there are alternatives
it's not a problem it costs the same
amount of money and they work just as
well because the Olympic teams are using
it and they're not having a problem and
as I say it's been banned since 19 uh
2021 so the purpose of this bill is to
add the that consumer product to the
list that we had from uh the previous
bill the bill 14 uh
1649 and that's about all it is it's
just to add that one product and I would
like to make a comment about why we
didn't add it last time although we did
think of it last time it wasn't added
last time because last time we were
concentrating on what ends up in the
landfill these products are directly
going into the water they're not going
into the landfill typically they go
directly into the water they're on this
water skis they're on the
uh Mountain SK downhill skiing and all
kinds of skis going directly into the
water so doesn't it's not typically a
landfill problem but goes directly into
the water now I wanted to point
out that the Lakes down here in the
southern part of the
state are are
4,000 to
26,000 times the fish that are caught in
these Lakes have have P at levels 4,000
and 26,000 times the EPA recommended
level and we have a number of lakes
Beaver Lake Robinson Pond and Hudson
Horseshoe Pond in Marram canaby Lake in
Salem and CET cobit L uh Pond and
Windham you're not even allowed to eat
the fish in those
Lakes so it the problem is pretty bad
and I think it's time to stop adding to
the problem and so that's what this bill
is
about any
questions nope
okay uh will anybody else like to
testify on House Bill
167 Bruce
so I get all I can do I can give my
little personal story there was a period
of time it was about I don't know how
long it was five years ago or something
because they uh I I don't know if it was
past or not because it didn't say it but
for my cross country skiing I was using
the liquid ski wax it's much easier than
the stick the that that all the
professionals use because then you got
to put it up you got to heat up your
thing you know this stuff this was
Liquid you just rub it all over it was
great and and but it dried up it was
like the marketplace suddenly
disappeared and I asked the guy up in
Jackson cross country ski I said do you
know what happened and he said I think
it was P so but the product is now back
on the market and assuming it's past
free I don't know but but it's now I can
now buy that product that I was buying
that I couldn't buy before so whether
it's past or not who knows but uh we did
create in the past legislation we did
create a a place where things can be
added and
um so and uh we knew full well that
things would get added over time um and
it just requires the companies who are
producing the product to have to report
to uh the uh
State Wetlands board well it's not the
wetlands but it's a a board that U with
the product and then they they have this
National Registry now in which they will
check this make sure it's
kosher with that if I
see no more close the he hearing on
167 minutes ahead of the game I guess I
was expecting a little bit
more more drama
that we used to use that's it was P oh
yeah I mean I rest
it e
so if you're going to testify on the
next
bill I'm guessing that maybe you're
there here for the the next bill one of
these bills you have to fill out a pink
card you guys
okay
e
e e
okay we'll open up the public hearing on
House Bill 312 and hear from the prime
sponsor representative Mett good
morning representative
M thank you Mr
chairman for the record uh I am
representative Mike
Moffett of miramac County District 4
which includes the beautiful towns of
Canterbury and Lowden uh I've introduced
many bills and many committees over the
years this the first time I believe I've
been in this historic Commerce Committee
so I'm a bit nervous but I'm sure it'll
work out so uh on June 21st 2021 there
was a unanimous US Supreme Court
decision in NCAA versus alustin Landmark
court case which cleared the way for
college student and athletes to Market
themselves commercially in ways that had
preious previously been uh prohibited by
the
NCAA and in a concurring opinion Brett
Kavanaugh stated that antitrust laws
quote should not be a cover for
exploitation of student athletes unquote
so the ruling gave College athletes uh
Freedom a lot more freedom uh and
control of their own name image and
likeness n ni we call it nil name image
and
likeness so the the legal action
actually started around 2014 when a
former UCLA basketball player named Edo
Bannon saw imagery of himself it was it
was him his number his uniform UCLA in a
video game and he saw that walked by he
said that's me and uh uh nobody asked me
if they could use my imagery for
commercial uh gain so anyway that was
the impetus and the Genesis behind the
court case it took as usual years so
anyway uh so now we have new sports
landscape or
sportscape um essentially the players
today are not unlike pro- free agents
there's a transfer portal uh some of you
follow Sports know that uh big- time
college football players and basketball
players especially football they're
going from college to college to college
uh willy-nilly
um one of them actually finished playing
six years as they get an extra year from
covid um so it's a different world uh
many years many years ago when I
transferred from UNH to Plymouth State I
I had to sit out a year before I could
play college basketball so anyway all
this newno found freedoms created some
situations that that do beg attention
with athletes now controlling their own
nil name image and likeness some see a
need for some guard rail some guard rail
some definition
uh for example what if players wanted to
endorse or tie in with foreign agents or
Chinese companies just to pick a country
um what if they wanted to tie in with
Casino or Sports gaming interests what
if they wanted to tie in with addictive
products uh tobacco alcohol or or or
others what if I heard uh representative
from Derry um mentioning um some
cannabis spill earlier
um what if a college athlete wanted to
sign an endorsement deal with Acapulco
Gold which many of you may not know
that's a marijuana brand uh currently
unavailable in New Hampshire I believe
um but but along those lines and that's
the reason that the inevitably
something's going to pop up what if the
college athlete was does want to endorse
aapco gold uh which is legal in
Massachusetts but not new I'm sure I
mean these things are on the horizon so
states have been devising statutes to
provide some boundaries with regard to
this brand new world of sports
endorsement the measure you're looking
at here HP 312 was modeled on a New
Jersey Law it says in paragraph one that
colleges cannot restrict student
athletes from marketing themselves and
earning compensation for the use of
their nil name image and likeness so
that's kind of a freedom paragraph
uh paragraph 2 requires athletes to be
represented by licensed attorneys now
some states allow anyone to represent
athletes I used to teach sports
management I used to uh I used to teach
a basic intro to sports law
course um and so New Hampshire now does
have some some irsa that cover sports
agency but um some states allow anyone
to be an agent kind of like Colonel Tom
Parker represented Elvis but a need was
seen to protect athletes from
Contracting with foreign agents or
unqualified
Representatives uh so as as the
committee reviews this it may want to
broaden paragraph to to include
registered Sports agents in addition to
licensed attorneys paragraph three uh
does requir Sports agents or attorneys
to comply with Federal sport agent law
there is a federal law covering sports
agency in uh finally paragraph four
seeks to restrict the endorsement
Universe for college athletes in other
words uh addictive drugs adult
entertainment uh you'll note and we did
model this on New Jersey you will note
that firearms and weapons are proscribed
as well and that may not fly in the live
Li fre your die State uh I'm looking
around to see if John burrett is going
to show up and say that College students
should be able to make deals with gun
companies and I I would not be
uncomfortable with that uh they could
they could be bathon athletes that's an
excellent point Mr chair bathon does
involve shooting and skiing is uh is the
hundreds of we just had the hundreds of
people watching at home yes banon
shooting and skiing excellent point uh
so also uh I not noticed uh the the
section of law uh
356 D Delta colon 3 already provides
some definition regarding contracts I
noticed that this section of law uh was
mostly tenant rights so that just tells
you OS and the in the U drafting
attorneys this is a new area so they had
to put this possible legislation
somewhere stud uh student athlete rights
uh following tenant rights
the the the measure about sports agency
that we put in law a couple years ago is
in a different section of of our
statute so just because other states
most other states have laws in this area
uh does that mean we need to that I was
just SP speaking with the good folks
from un outside um there there's
no uh fire that needs to be put out uh
this the intent of this is to be
proactive uh
preemptive uh get this on your radar
screens and uh inevitably they're going
to be some things that are going to pop
up that need
attention uh New York uh New Hampshire
is not California we're not New York
we're not we're not even
Massachusetts we don't have a lot of
major college sports action uh or major
corporations who' be getting into
serious commercial Partnerships uh the
sports Cape is changing Dartmouth
basketball men's basetball recently
unionized although they backed off of
that uh had they had the union stayed in
place could the union have made a deal
with uh representing the whole team a a
commercial deal uh it's a move point
right now with the Dartmouth men's
basketball unionized effort having
stopped but that again is a type of
thing that is going to happen is going
to come up and that we will need to
address at some point but also uh small
school athletes are now free to
similarly makes commercial Arrangements
it's not just this is important it's not
just big schools division 3 non-s
scholarship small schools athletes can
Market themselves now now I was no Larry
Bird I was a small fish in a small pond
but had the had NC versus alter that's
Supreme Court case passed back when I
was around I can totally see a
fraternity brother majoring in business
saying hey let's uh let's do some
posters let's do a calendar uh let's see
if we can get uh uh you to Fred Ford or
the seller Pub to be a uh
endorser uh alcohol by the way um is
prescribed uh it's one of the things uh
that the laws have uh prohibited and
when I mentioned alcohol uh when I was
in college the drinking age was 18 so
that was a that was different this
legislature and its wisdom had lowered
the drinking age to 18 the day after I
turned 18 and that uh timing is
everything but that uh obviously that's
not the case today but whether it's
alcohol or or uh or drugs or substances
those are things that are out there that
need to be uh considered at some point
so uh some schools probably already have
local policies addressing nil issues I
just talked as I mentioned with the UNH
folks and and good on them they already
have started and apparently have some
policies in place and and you'll
probably hear from them but what if
these college policies differ uh UNH has
some policies in place it sounds like uh
dmouth but what what about southern New
Hampshire University what if they have
uh policies that are in conflict and
this is right this is where someday
there's going to be a lawsuit saying
well you know college a says uh their
athletes can can um do this and college
B my college says we can't that's not
you know and then there will be a a
lawsuit so
so again some preemptive uh legislation
might um put us ahead of that game um
for example if a college student in the
band can wear Dartmouth hockey shirts
while getting paid for a music gig why
can't the Dartmouth cheerleaders
similarly wear Dartmouth hockey shirts
and do a calendar for their own profit
miss you know Miss January wearing a
Dartmouth hoey shirt um if people who
have music skills can Market themselves
why can't people have athletic skills in
college so anyway uh commercial deals we
never dreamed of are going to pop up and
to establish a section of law in this
area could provide some early definition
in a place to put appropriate future
sections in down the road as necessary
um I'd be happy to try to take any
questions if there are
any representative pusk thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question representative Moffett uh
actually it's an
observation um line seven on on page one
I guess it says accredited four-year
institutions uh I suspect you are aware
that there are two-year institutions
that are now accredited and offering
scholarships uh to athletes so I'd like
to see that you know considered that you
also have for two-year
institutions thank you representative uh
yes I am aware that there are two-year
institutions that do Sports uh I spent
20 years at a two-year institution
actually and they coach the basketball
team there for three of those years uh
that's an excellent
observation uh and it's true it's a very
good point because uh some two-year
school there were different classes uh I
I worked at nhti non-s scholarship
obviously exactly there are two-year
schools that do offer scholarships but
whether they offer scholarships or not
um nil the the Supreme Court case means
that these students uh if and I'm sure
that the the wheels are turning some of
them are thinking of ways to make money
as wearing as athletes uh so good point
it we should also acknowledge uh the
fact that there are two years follow for
the question me inquire thank you Mr
chair also on page two lines four and
five uh I would really appreciate if you
could get with of the
weapons uh piece because uh when I was
in the Explorer Scouts I was a shooter
and uh it it made me do very well when I
went to Air Force basic
training uh and uh the Shooting Sports I
believe are sports so I would hope that
that part would be amended
out yes thank you uh representative uh I
already touched on that because when I
reread this uh that's that's where the
uh reference to John Burt came into
place he's a former representative who
is a very staunched second amendment
advocate so I I again this came was
largely modeled on the New Jersey statue
which we fine-tuned and I I the the the
gun situation in New Jersey is very
different from New Hampshire and I I I
mentioned that on my own and and you you
just did too and I if this moves forward
whatever the committee does with it uh
if you took the gun part out uh uh that
would not be an issue for me and I as I
can I follow up I guess you as as I used
to live in New Jersey I'm extremely
aware of the uh
anti-nra uh sentiments down there thank
you would you believe would you believe
representative
Ammon thank you Mr chair thank you
representative mfet for your testimony
Ju Just because I don't understand one
section I want to ask you about uh page
one of the bill line 14 that paragraph
there it talks about International
Scholarship if you could just
explain uh it says
their nil shall not affect the students
International Scholarship eligibility
and it and
it oh institutional it's because I don't
have my glasses
on as bad as me there we go
institutional uh and it shall not be
considered compensation for the purposes
of this chapter if you could just
explain what that means I I don't
understand sure I'm trying to find the
line uh again that's
uh on your page what what line line is
that it's the first page of the bill
line 14 through
18 right my copy doesn't have the uh the
line numbers that yours
does b b little B yeah little B D2 one
Roman one
subb uh 1 D is it starts prevent a
student participating in in Collegiate
death except as it's right near the
beginning except as otherwise provided
pursuant to paragraph 2 that that
paragraph section B
Baker
um don't go away so where where is that
is right here I just saw you talking
about
L okay well this one has the thank you
thank you so much uh that that's a very
nice lady whoever that was um so line 14
accept as otherwise provided pursuant to
paragraph two that line yeah that
paragraph okay uh earning compensation
from the use of a student's nil shall
not affect a student's institutional
scholarship eligibility right
um
so the concern in the past has been that
it used to be if you were on scholarship
the NCAA had prohibitions you couldn't
uh be you couldn't do this you couldn't
uh make
money endorsement money money uh through
um you know selling your nil name image
and likeness so what 14 says uh it
refers to uh this shall not affect the
students institutional scholarship
eligibility in other words uh if a if a
college student um makes a big deal and
they when I say makes a big deal makes a
has a contract it makes a lot of money
uh that shouldn't take away a
scholarship if they get a scholarship
they should be able to uh make a lot of
money real quick along those lines uh
Terry Rogers there was a Nebraska uh
football player who was a wonderful
football player and he was on
scholarship and he they offered him a
deal to be a sports writer which which
I've done and so the fact that that this
football player was writing a sports
column and getting a lot of money for
the sports column they made him take
some of that money he made from writing
the sports column and take it away from
his scholarship which uh I I thought was
terrible but that's what the NCAA did
this court case has changed that so now
the the football player who wrote the
sports column could keep all that money
um and he would keep a scholarship so uh
yeah great question I I see your
question and and uh this would protect
students who are on scholarship of which
in New Hampshire we don't have very many
uh UNH does have some people on
scholarship so if someone at UNH was on
scholarship athletic scholarship and and
they made a deal and were making a ton
of money elsewhere in una's financial
aid whatever looks at that person said
well you're rich now you don't we don't
need to give you scholarship this
protects them from losing their
scholarship doesn't the Supreme Court
decision already do that
did the question was does it doesn't the
Supreme Court decision say that the
school the schools the NCAA and schools
were originally
rebar you know you know the students was
rebar from doing it did that decision
when that decision I guess we need to
get a copy of the decision and see
what's in it but didn't it address the
issue of of uh the repercussions of of a
student doing it that the school would
do this or I mean did did it was that
that issue mute sure Mr chairman I'm
tracking you uh I'd have to look at the
language in the Supreme Court decision
but you're right the intent of the
Supreme Court decision was to free the
players to be a to allow them to to you
know uh commercialize their let name
image and likeness and uh the Supreme
Court that I believe the Supreme Court
case covers that so uh we got to look
and see what the decision said right I
know the statutes all over the country
now uh affirming that Supreme Court uh
case but there are there are situations
where definition is will be right
because what I'm my Furious what this
bill is really doing is is telling is
saying okay fine we got this decision
but now here's the things the students
can't do right well again I'm not sure I
I think that's a good idea I mean I why
shouldn't if the student wants to do
tobacco wants to do video games and
wants to do the you know these whatever
sin that someone thinks that New Jersey
thinks is a sin right okay that if they
want to do these things then who are we
to say no they can't do it if that if
the Supreme Court had ruled that that
that that the NCAA and the colleges
can't say no uh and and I agree that
there shouldn't be any repercussions you
know shouldn't you know against the
student but shouldn't we just let let
let bygones May byon and let them
advertise wherever they want to
advertise with I totally get your point
uh and Live Free or Die uh again the the
first paragraph the first part of this
uh HB uh reaffirms or confirms the
freedom part of it you know there are
four parts of this and I I hear you and
I get your point I had similar thoughts
and as I said the the language we did
use use from another state to model this
uh this proposal uh and I've already
said the the paragraph four uh the parts
of that that uh I'm not that comfortable
with should basically I think your
question is should we as a state
prescribe or prohibit athletes from end
endorsing part uh some people think we
should uh you'll notice we have a lot of
sponsors for this measure and not all
sponsors are necessarily in sync on
whether we should Outlaw uh College
athletes from endorsing fair enough
represent
Teresa so uh thank you for taking a
question um so the the scholarship that
you mentioned is it uh strictly Merit
based scholarship or is it also need
based scholarship uh good question uh
does Scholarships in question are they
academic or athletic is that kind of
what your question is yeah so on that
that paragraph we say they they
shouldn't affect the scholarship so
scholarship can be need- based or uh it
can be uh Merit based so it does it
refer to all the scholarships or or it
refers only to uh Merit based
scholarship sure that's a great question
it's an interesting question because
there are clearly athletic scholarships
and there financial aid and there are
some scholarships somebody could be on a
academic scholarship
and so uh the the language here about uh
protecting scholarships if somebody
makes a lot of money uh would that
impact a an academic scholarship uh
depending upon what the committee does
with this that's interesting point that
may want to confirm uh that it also you
know this legislation would also protect
uh academic scholarships if if a uh if a
student uh perhaps a non-athlete uh gets
Rich from selling their nil uh they
should their their academic scholarship
should also be safe I that's the type of
thing that's uh that's going to be
happening more and more is with this new
world thank you for your question
represent
Gibbs thank you Mr chair and thank you
for coming in to testify this morning um
how would this affect need-based
scholarships which are based on how much
money the student or the student's
family has thank you for your question
how would this affect need-based
scholarships I don't think it would
affect need-based at all this is a
sports type uh sports related measure uh
directly tied to the Supreme Court case
so need-based scholarships that through
financial aid uh I I just don't see that
them being impacted unless it's an
athlete uh who's getting money uh for
financial because of their athletic
situation in which case the language
here is intended to protect
scholarship further question may inquire
thank you um so did I understand
correctly that um need-based
scholarships would not be
protected not by thank you for your
question not not by the language in here
that was not the intent was to protect
need-based scholarships uh that that
would be something locally that
institutions uh their policies would
would cover um again the focus here was
on on um student athletes but but uh
people in a band people in the marching
band who have wonderful music skills if
they uh wear a a UNH hockey jersey in
their band uh there are going to be
potential trademark issues I I know I'm
throwing a lot of stuff out there but
these are things that are coming and uh
to start start the process of of maybe
putting one
line into legislation so that when these
things come to us uh there'll be a place
to uh to go to uh to fix them isn't this
bill discriminatory so uh a Harvard
student who happens to invent Facebook
while he's a student and makes millions
of dollars he doesn't have to worry
about put his face on on the product but
a call Harvard football player
does yes I get you the point is well
taken and um I I understand that what
you're saying and and uh and again this
this is this is sports Centric you got
it all
right okay um before I let you go and
this is really for everybody in the room
um uh the Commerce Committee has
actually visited this type of issue
already and it was related to JD
Salinger and JD Salinger was very upset
that he he didn't want anybody to ever
see his picture
uh and when he lived in in uh corish in
Cornish yeah and uh uh and the first
Scandal was that some guy was
advertising that his he had a toilet he
was a plumber and he had his toilet and
he was advertising it was JD salinger's
toilet and he had it on on on Google or
something you know something but then
but the issue the bill came into is
protection of people's identity the bill
was put in by his family and oh my God
we got emails from every sports athlete
all over the country hockey B there all
of them it turns out that the NFL can
use people's image on their Madden
because they have a contract with the
Players Association all right so what
this is really getting into is obviously
this is college students and that means
the contract between the college and the
student and getting that scholarship and
that in Rel reltionship that contractual
Arrangement so it's somewhat related so
we will do a little research on this was
back in 2011 2012 is when we had that
bill but at the end of the day my memory
was we killed the bill uh because
basically we didn't want to get involved
in this contractual Arrangement and that
if the Supreme Court rules that that
college students can have sell their
picture and and do it with anybody they
want then all the power to them I'm
tracking you Mr chairman um but as I
said that there are things that are
coming at us and so we we're trying to
start to anticipate them and and uh and
be proactive and I I'm sure Congress
committee uh whatever you do with this
uh with this measure will be uh will be
enlightened I'm sure thank you thank you
very much thank you all all right chair
we'll call on representative Pressa who
uh is in support of the bill
thank you Mr
chairman uh my name is Adam pieza I
represent Hillsboro District 12 I am in
support of this bill with the exception
of removing page two lines 20 through 23
section
4 that allows the institution and any
athletic body governing that to use the
athletes naming image likeness without
compensating the
athlete the majority of athletes
especially in New Hampshire don't get
any nil
money there's many D3 programs that
don't have the exposure for it and what
you see is a lot of athletes on top of
School athletics having to work a
job to just pay the pay their basic rent
food everything else and I think that
takes away a lot from both the Athletics
and the academics portion as a former
division 3 athlete and a current college
coach I think that
that if this was removed it would allow
the athletes to focus a lot more on
those two
subjects yeah that's about it actually
that's
it okay I'm gonna play The Devil's
Advocate is if we were not to pass this
bill at all would you be S is there
something in here that you really want
us to pass yeah
on page one line
23 the athlete needs to be represented
by have legal representation provided by
attorneys I think when this bill first
passed there were a lot of companies
preying on some athletes I can't
remember the athletes name but last year
an athlete received a few
hundred, and in return the company
received 25% of that athletes earnings
for the next 20 years I think that's
unacceptable because athlete that
athlete didn't any
representation and he came from a poor
family and he just took the money
because his family needed it but now
he's in this long contract where he's
forced to give that company everything
he earns for the next two
decades so I do think there should be
some representation for the athlete
isn't that like an agent I think it
should be legal representation and I if
this that's the only thing that passes
in this spell before
it right but I mean it does isn't didn't
he treat that company as an agent that
they were going to promote him or
yeah but the company was praying on the
fact that he needed the money and I feel
like if there he was represented by an
attorney he'd be able to negotiate a
better opt offer oh he didn't have
proper repres he had no representation
it was just him no but this that's
what okay got says an institution shall
not
prevent that is under all that
section so it's affirming what you want
on page one
yeah chairman asked there if there was
anything else for the bill so I was just
pointing out you were looking for the
positive right yeah okay positive is we
would make sure that any student that
did did this that they had proper
representation and make sure they know
what they're
signing sounds fair enough to me okay no
questions from the committee members
thank you very much uh I have one more
card left here and it looks like is this
a tag team okay
Laura banker and Allison
Ridge good morning Mr chair members
committee um for the record my name is
Lauren Banker I serve as the senior
director of government relations for the
University system of New Hampshire I'm
joined by my colleague Allison Rich
who's a director of um uh director of
Athletics at the University of New
Hampshire um we are here in opposition
to HB 312 um I just wanted to give a
brief summary and then I'm going to pass
it along to my colleague to talk a
little bit more about some technical
concerns that we have with the
legislation um as well as uh maybe some
clarification on some of the questions
that were asked earlier
so the university system of New
Hampshire supports a students right to
profit from their name image and
likeness um also known as nil and our
campuses have policies in place to
support students in their efforts to do
so we believe this bill is problematic
given the everchanging climate of nil
provisions on the national level and
we're strongly urging uh the legislature
to avoid developing a patchwork system
that could undermine our ability to
attract and retain uh student athletes
in New Hampshire we're seeing a lot of
demographic changes now it's um very
competitive in the higher ed landscape
and anything we can do to um keep
athletes um keep student athletes keep
students attract and retain them to stay
um in New Hampshire and go to our
institutions um is something that we
really prioritize and um we have
concerns with this legislation being
able to undermine that um so I'll pass
it along to my colleague who can speak a
little bit more too sure thank you very
much for having me again excuse me my
name is Allison Rich I'm the director of
Athletics at the University of New
Hampshire um just a a brief uh overview
very brief um name image and likeness
this was something that originally was
not permitted by the NCAA so if a
student athlete wrote a book or created
a product or wanted to be an influencer
um he or she had to separate who they
were as an athlete from their ability to
profit so they couldn't use the
reputation as an
athlete this was something that was
evolving over the years the NCA was
looking at changing this so that student
athletes could do everything that
non-student athletes could do uh the
Austin case um just to clarify a little
bit that case regarded um educational
benefits it was not related to name
image and likeness but it was right at
the same time that name image image and
likeness rules were being created uh by
the NCAA so they it gets confused quite
a bit so that um precludes institutions
from limiting the amount of educational
benefits that are received by student
athletes so there's a a cap right now of
$ 5980 a year that a student athlete can
receive on top of their scholarship on
their educational benefits how much was
that I'm sorry $5,988 I know it's it's
really a a strange number why not six um
so so that's so the timing of that when
the Austin case was decided there was
some uh comments by the Department of
Justice the NCAA saying you should be
very careful about the regulations that
you impose on anything regarding a
student athletes ability to earn money
um so the name the a name image and
likeness roles by the NCAA were created
permissible so all student athletes uh
at any level of NCA school can
participate in name image and likeness
activities that that rule was passed in
July of 2021 there are a number of
states that do have nil laws in place
and many of those were created in 2020
or 2021 before the NCA rules were passed
in an effort to protect students to say
if your if your the nciaa prohibits you
from participating in nil the state law
will override that and say that you can
so many of these are somewhat moot um
they're still in place one has already
been repealed a few have been um
modified significantly to make them less
and less stringent so as NC as the n n
has developed over the years student
athletes have been able to participate
and they do at UNH we do have policies
in place to protect the student athletes
we recommend that they reach out and
connect with an advisor or an agent if
they are um uh entering into contracts
um it's not required but we do we do uh
recommend that of them we help them if
they have questions of how to select
that type of representation um and that
has been that is permissible so this
this bill wouldn't change that um that
is permissible for all student athletes
to to participate in right now right now
we're as many of you probably know the
NCA is in a an interesting situation um
we have an impending potential
settlement of three antitrust cases
known collectively as the house uh
settlement uh that if it is approved by
finally by the by the judge will go into
effect will it be approved in the
beginning of April will go into effect
this summer um what that that will do is
it will change a little bit of the
relationship the dynamic of relationship
between schools and student athletes so
it will still maintain the nil
opportunities it will allow schools to
bring nil in house so that if a donor
would like to give money um to a student
athlete for their name imtion likeness
actual work performed that's something
that will be in effect as well um that
that will be permitted so there'll be a
number of changes coming there are also
several um bills in the um state in the
Senate and in the house regarding name
image and likeness and student athletes
um and their status as employees
hopefully not employees and so there's a
lot of things happening right now in
this landscape so we don't know exactly
what it's going to look like the the
bill I I recognized this bill because I
I was at Princeton University before
this and was very familiar with the New
Jersey bill um which was enacted but has
not gone into effect yet because it was
again as a preemptive measure measure
and would be effective five five
academic years after uh it was enacted
and I think that was really to maintain
you know to to ensure that MCA rules
were changed student athletes were
protected all of that um I haven't heard
a lot right now about it going to effect
but I think if all of this changes with
the house case you will see that that
bill or that law will probably go away
um because it's not necessary anymore so
um there there was a time when these
laws were were important because we
wanted to make sure students had these
the ability to capitalize on their name
image and likeness right now we're kind
of moving in the other direction because
all schools are permitting this students
have a great opportunity to um to make
money on their name image and likeness
and they have a lot more autonomy than
ever before um at UNH we use this as an
opportunity to provide them additional
education we provide them Financial
education we talk to them about
contracts um we we help them with how do
you how do you look for Meaningful and
real opportunities as opposed to
somebody that might come and take
advantage so there's a lot more
information that student athletes have
so for us it's been a great opportunity
to talk about these things and help our
student athletes with that type of
education that will help them in the
rest of their lives whether they ever
enter into an ni deal nil deal or not um
and they also have opportunities we have
jersey sales where they're profiting on
the sale of of their name on those
jerseys
um some of them are representing local
companies and and we'll continue to do
so and we're going to do everything we
can to support them in their abilities
uh to be able to capitalize on that so
this bill um would be a little more
restrictive potentially than what's
happening um it would not permit student
the schools to be involved in the
process with right now we are permitted
to not enter into deals with student
athletes but to connect um so we have
sponsors that we've linked with our
student athletes who are who are hiring
them to do this legitimate work um other
companies uh alums things like that that
would be something that we would not be
permitted to do um if this bill were to
pass um and eventually we'd like to be
able to do some in-house um which would
allow our donors to give directly um to
the school to be given to the student
athletes so um there are Protections in
place for student athletes um there's
also nothing in this bill um that's
relative to international student
athletes and international student
athletes right now um based on federal
law not permitted to earn money um for
their nil u in this country they can do
it in their home country so again want
to make sure that those student athletes
are are protected as well so right now
um I think we're in a really good spot U
we've been managing nil and expanding
the opportunities for our student
athletes um we're staying on top of
every change uh nationally federally
with the NCAA and we'll continue to do
so and I think we're able to do that and
uh and really provide a great experience
our student athletes re recruit and
retain outstanding student athletes
instead of them potentially going
elsewhere where where it's a little
easier for them to capitalize on the on
nil we want it to we want it to be a
great experience once they get to our
school they love it they stay many of
them move to New Hampshire and stay here
as adults and and live their lives here
and business so we love contributing to
the state that way our student athletes
love it at UNH we just want to make sure
that we have the ability to bring them
here and to retain them with all the
opportunities that student athletes have
in other states so I'll be happy to
answer any
questions I think we're all set thank
you very much thank you very much much
thank
you having no more cards we'll close the
public hearing on 312 and running
late uh blue sheet yeah blue sheet is
uh representative he Heath Hower was in
support okay next up is 427
[Music]
okay we'll open up the public hearing on
House Bill 427 and here from the prime
sponsor good morning represent
bernady good morning chairman hunt and
committee uh for the record I'm
representative JD Bernardi Rockingham 36
Southampton Newton plastow Hampton Falls
and Kensington um
I'm here to introduce House Bill 427
which is amending the the UCC it really
deals with two subjects uh predominant
portion is ownership of Securities and I
also have a section on deposit accounts
I provided you a handout so you can
follow along as I'm um speaking here and
I also provided the testimony of uh
attorney Don Grandy who who more
eloquently legally explains the
issue so what is the universal excuse me
Uniform Commercial Code it's the
commercial Bible it has a goal of
substantial uniformity of rules for
business
transactions excluding real property
that will facilitate
Commerce individual states can can adopt
or reject proposals to suit local needs
adoption is generally uniform but not
universally
so proposals are generated by the
American law Institute and the National
Conference of Commissioners of the
uniform state laws New Hampshire has
representation along with all the other
states so the first section I'd like to
speak about
um is uh section five of the bill uh
simple provision it's IT addresses RSA
382a 9102
a29 it disallows programmable medium of
exchange as an identified deposit
account so what is this doing it's
essentially prohibiting Central Bank
digital
currency Central Bank digital currency
can more readily be understood as
monetary coupons the issuer since it's a
coupon can control the time and place of
use create quotas for usage of that
quote unquote currency and cause it to
expire at will this is a fantastic deal
if you're a government issuer and you
want to control people control Commerce
or use the excuse to control inflation
it's a horrible deal for we the people I
encourage your adoption of section
five the remainder of the bill deals
with the ownership of
Securities both yesterday and
today when we buy stock now and I'm on
this
page you the the Money Follows the path
from you as the investor to The
Brokerage and eventually to the banks
and what is known as a depository trust
clearance
Corporation in in the 1990s on the next
page the
UCC amend was
amended and that Amendment many have
dubbed the Armageddon
plan so what we're doing is rather than
purchasing stock now we're purchasing
security entitlements
they become part of a large anonymized
deidentified stock pool held by the DT
dtcc the pool can be used as collateral
by the custodian of the
dtcc note we could have adopted tracing
so your ownership could be tracked into
that pool that has not been
done the ramifications of this really
appear when there is a financial crisis
a liquidity crisis the ucc's provisions
that we're amending provide that the two
big to fail
Banks JP Morgan Wells Fargo Bank of
America Chase Manhattan those that crowd
have priority to your Investments
because they now been deidentified from
you if the asss are needed to pay the
debts of the broker or insolvency of the
custodian you get to sue for the
crumbs it's that simple HB
reestablishes ownership of people's
secuity and
money now we are not the only state
looking at this many have said or propos
propos that oh go back to the UCC
commission have them make an amendment
send it through the
process they did this and they did this
on
purpose there are other states that are
not waiting for uh us to go that route
13 have already proposed legislation
three more are working on
drafts I present to you one other code
that offers more Universal
guidance Thou shalt not
steal with that I encourage passage of
uh of HP
427 uh and I again uh refer you to Don
Grandy's more legalistic testimony and I
will also note that uh David Webb is
here uh from Sweden he is the author of
the book The Great taking he has in deep
knowledge of this entire process and how
these rules came into being and uh would
be more than willing to answer all your
questions and I will take I have his
card but this other person Don I don't
have I don't have his no he he is not
here you just have his testimony okay oh
the testimony that I got okay great all
right any questions from the committee
members representative
Gibbs thank you Mr chair and thank you
for coming in this morning to testify I
have two questions the first first is
what is the
dtcc if you look at the uh the slide on
how you're you're uh you're buying
stock depository trust and clearance
Corporation I'm sorry depository trust
and clearance Corporation it's where all
this all these stocks get uh anonymized
deidentified and put into a big pool
that can be used as collateral by the
custodian thank you and the second uh
question is when I read this spill last
night I understood programmable medium
of exchange to apply to all types of
cryptocurrency not just currency issued
by the government um why wouldn't it
apply to all types of crypto
cryptocurrency I don't believe
cryptocurrency is in uh is considered a
deposit account and this is amending the
language of deposit
account well no um it it says it does
not include a programmable medium of
exchange okay and you've said that the
programmable medium of exchange would
only be governmen issued
cryptocurrency and my question is why
doesn't that include all
cryptocurrency again the the only thing
I can say is the language in section
five is amending the definition of a
deposit account so
um I I don't think cryptocurrency is
currently considered that potentially
representative Ammon is in a better
position to answer that than I
am yeah it definition probably needs to
be cleared and because yes the crypto is
a commodity whereas we are talking about
uh fiduciary you know exactly you know
money we're talking about money we're
talking about money what is it f ficia
what is it finza so finza stuff yes so
that is the difference so but yes
probably so is this model legislation or
where where would you have gotten this
this this language where did this come
from it is it is model legislation that
several of the other states are also
pursuing yes so they they the just the
general assumption is that in terms of a
what a deposit account means uh and I
would say my when I first arrived here
on this committee deposit account always
meant a cash checking account it's a
it's cash it had it had a monetary value
so um I I do I think that what happened
was is that the nature of this
legislation was that they want to add
this program ofal medium exchange into
it uh so that in to clarify what it can
or can't
be right so it means it not can't be
Bitcoin so crypto right any can't be any
cryptocur because that's a commodity
anyways okay represented
spirit right now of all about 160 some
OD countries looked into Central Bank
digital
currency only 15% went ahead with it the
United States has laws uh has Bills
currently before both the Senate and the
house to forbid it the Federal Reserve
says they are not interested in it and
don't want any part of
it why do we think we need a law to
prohibit something that no one wants to
do well the European Union just created
a digital
wallet what do you put in a digital
wallet
Euros or programmable currencies so it
it is a preventative measure uh we
changed the administration again and we
may have an entirely different point of
view so this is
protective
for thank you
okay thank you very much thank you okay
so David
web all the way from Sweden
yeah thank you for the opportunity
to thank you for the opportunity to
speak with you I'm I'm
grateful um let me Begin by saying for
four
centuries Securities were personal
property
now what that meant was the in the event
of insolvency in the financial
system you the public were absolutely
bulletproof because it was your property
your personal property that's why they
were called
Securities now what that meant was if
your intermediary failed you could say
I'm sorry you're out of business here's
where you deliver my stuff
that has been
subverted now how do we know that it's
plain as day you cannot revindicate
revindicate means to take back your own
Securities out of the insolvency of a
financial
intermediary you were no longer able to
do that now how do we know that we know
that because when Europe was being
pressured to conform to this us model
they formed something called the legal
certainty group to investigate how to do
it now what they meant by legal
certainty is legal certainty that the
secured creditors keep the assets that's
what they meant by legal certainty
finality certainty of finality so what
they what they what they have done is to
shift this certainty from the public
being absolutely bulletproof in the
event of catastrophic failure to the
secured creditors being absolutely
bulletproof in a catastropic
catastrophic failure it's a shift shift
of this legal certainty so how do we
know this the legal certainty group sent
a detailed questionnaire to the New York
fed the New York fed is the fed this is
the business end of the Fed and
attorneys for the FED responded to that
questionnaire in March of
2006 um they
specifically state that they are
commenting on the operation of UCC
article 8 and portions of article 9 so
we have a definitive primary source
document directly from the top of the
financial system this this document will
not be acknowledged by anyone you will
hear from from the UN uniform law
commission it will not be acknowledged
by the Securities industry financial
Market Association they they they don't
seem to know that this document
exists um the FED makes clear that
Securities are held in pooled form you
do not have the right to revindicate the
Securities out of insolvency in the and
in the event of insolvency the investor
is always
vulnerable further that and they put
this in
quotations segregation segregated
accounts that has no
effect now how is this how is this being
done your relationship is with a lower
level intermediary in the
system um you're a a brokerage firm or a
custodian you have a contract with them
but the property is actually held at a
higher level in the system and you have
no
relationship with the with that entity
that is holding the property and
once uh Securities enter a chain of uses
collateral they are reused many times
over these these chain of collateral use
and reuse hypothecation and
rehypothecation of Securities are very
very long now so this this what enabled
this was the amendments to the Uniform
Commercial Code in
1994 the so this Federal Reserve
Document Speaks specifically to this
another very important document is
something called policy perspectives
that was published in the UCLA law
review in
1996 that is a detailed historical
discussion of this by James S Rogers who
was the drafter he wrote the changes to
the
UCC he he talks about this being done
for Armageddon planning this isn't this
isn't uh other people saying this this
is the drafter so the intent this was
not about modernizing the system making
it more convenient more efficient this
was about about
ensuring that certainty was shifted to
the the secured creditors in the event
of financial
failure um another very important thing
to understand is the failure of Leman
Brothers in uh in in the last financial
crisis 2008 2009 there um the the people
that say there's nothing to be done here
will say well no one lost any money in
the failure of lemman Brothers the
important thing to understand is that
all client accounts were frozen the
moment that bankruptcy was filed so
retail accounts were sold the clients
weren't able to take their money back
out of their accounts in the teeth of a
CL a crisis it took it took some weeks
and months for those accounts to be sold
and then they could have access to them
again but the the the bigger thing that
happened here is many sophisticated
institutional clients unbeknownst to
them their treasury Securities their
collateral was being used by Layman
Brothers under swap contracts to arrange
financing for Leman Brothers which is
common practice there is nothing unusual
about that um and as long as the music
doesn't stop those clients would never
know that their Securities were being
used but the music stopped now this is
the very interesting thing JP Morgan was
the custodian for client assets JP
Morgan was also the secured creditor
that took the client
Assets Now imagine this this is in the
teeth of a terrible Financial collapse
those firms relied on on that collateral
to be able to
operate um so five years later there was
a Bankruptcy Court decision in the
southern district court of
Manhattan um what was happening there
was these sophisticated clients these
are the big boys you would think
wouldn't run a file of something like
this they were suing 5 years later still
trying to recover their
collateral and the bankruptcy court the
judge found that JP Morgan was entitled
to take the take their
assets um the only consideration was
whether JP Morgan was in the protected
class to be able to take these assets
and that's basically the largest
financial institutions have this super
priority to keep the Assets in a
collapse and they need that because
there are so many claimants the the
Securities are now used so many times
over so this is a real issue there's
another
document a bank for international
settlements document from
2014 um about um the collateral
management system that we now have
globally and there's a chart in this
showing the flow of collateral from
collateral givers to Collateral takers
collateral givers are everything Equity
trading desks Bond death custodians
globally that flows through a collateral
management system that operates
particularly in a time of crisis when
the value of the collateral is calling
so there will be more and more calls for
more
collateral where that is going the
destination the collateral takers are
the central clearing
counterparties that house the
derivatives complex this is this is um
um where the collateral is being used
now when they made this change in 1994
to allow the use of these pooled assets
legally they were doing it illegally
prior to this they had to paper it
over that is there's no coincidence that
that is when the derivatives complex
began
exploding so in 2001 it was about $110
trillion by 2007 it was 700 trillion 700
trillion 10 times Global GDP it's
estimated that now it may be 20 times
Global GDP this is this this is where
the collateral is being
used um and ultimately that's where it
will be taken Behind these um these
contracts so so when when we own the
property as
certificates um we had certainty now we
have something that functions like a
contract this idea of a Securities
entitlement that is very weak in the
event of insolvency but at the other end
of the food chain certainty has been
given two contracts these derivative
contracts but only for the biggest banks
that are behind those contracts and this
is the Armageddon planning now how do we
face up to this how do we understand it
in the
UCC you will see the statements that the
entitlement holder has priority over the
secured creditor of the
intermediary and that is the statement
that was promulgated to sell the
amendments to the UCC in
1994 what they neglected to show was
there were two exceptions to that and
that's what this bill does is simply and
elegantly removing those exceptions
under which the collateral you know
leaves the barn you know the barn door
is open and the collateral is out um so
these um so by striking these exceptions
you then just have language that the
entitlement holders have priority to
their own
assets um these Exceptions there are two
that have to be we have to remove the
first is that if the secured creditor of
the intermediary has control
the secured creditor has priority
control is a concept from bankruptcy law
which means just the ability to act upon
the asset now what we know with paper
certificates it was clear who had
control by
dematerializing it becomes unclear who
has control but the what you know is the
control always resides
elsewhere um at a at a higher level in
the system the second ception is that if
the secured creditor is a creditor of um
a clearing
entity that secured creditor always has
priority clearing entities are basically
any broker a clearing a clearing firm
it's it's Leman Brothers It's Goldman
Sachs and it is certainly depository
trust and Clearing
Corporation
um so I I probably said enough for now
I'm I'm sure you have a lot of concerns
and questions and I'm I'm available now
and
later so you're not in Stockholm you
you'll be here for our
subcommittee uh when will that be I
don't know how long you here at State
Side uh I just came over to do this
actually okay yeah uh yeah we wouldn't
uh the subcommittee would be uh can't
even be next week would have to be the
week
after okay it's possible if possible I
can come back absolutely that would be
great just a quick question
representative Sullivan's hand I saw
first okay thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking my question and thanks
for coming here from Stockholm
um so just to make sure I understand
what's going on here so I I use Char
Schwab as my brokerage I buy some stock
in Dollar General just bought that this
week that's why I say that um but I uh
so I buy that and then you're saying
Charles I don't technically own it like
we think I do I think I do but I don't
technically own it the way you're
describing it to me it gets sent to
perhaps another bank or maybe Charles
Schwab itself to use as collateral to
run other sort of security type
Arrangements derivatives whatever is
that what you're telling me yeah I'll
let me what you have you'll hear this
term beneficial ownership that is a term
you'll see it in some of your documents
beneficial ownership is a term that
arose coincident with these changes in
'94 beneficial ownership is basically an
appearance of ownership they make it
appear that you own it because you can
vote the shares you can buy and sell
them it works like ownership in every
case except
insolvency that's the Armageddon
planning so how to what happens is
literally all securities are pulled at
depository trust clearing Corp this
houses the entire Securities complex of
the United States and much of the world
it's all there so any individual broker
is a clearing member of depository trust
and essentially has an account at
depository trust where all of the client
Securities are pulled there with no
specific identification of any person to
any security so and that's how they're
able to use those Securities for the
firm's purposes now James Rogers in this
document policy perspectives he says um
what do Securities firms do they sell
Securities and the party that has bought
that security has no idea whether they
did that uh uh wrongly they don't know
whose security it was they they are
entitled to finality of settlement what
do Securities firms do they borrow money
using Securities they do that under swap
contracts so um who the party on the
other side of that contract they can't
know whose Securities were being used so
um the he also explains in this document
that when they were coming up with this
approach many attorneys were uncom
fortable with the idea that the
Securities could be used
wrongfully and he said after careful
consideration they eventually agreed as
I say they got more expensive
attorneys um so so they eventually
agreed that the Securities can be used
wrongfully the fed's
response to the legal certainty group
says in that even fault from fraud and
negligence does not prevent the secured
creditor from taking the Securities so
this is um this is a
reality um we if you're in the security
system you just have an appearance of
ownership as a direct answer to what
you're saying it's important to
understand this is not just small
investors this is important for States
this is the pension plans of the state
this is the finances of the state the
another important thing to understand is
the the the the tiny interests that
benefit from this that run the banking
system really at the highest
level uh they want people in the
financial services industry to think
we're all on the same side in this we're
protecting you actually the financial
service people in financial service
let's say in the state they are at the
bottom of the food chain they are the
intermediaries that will incur the wrath
of their clients they will when their
assets are
lost um the the the financial services
firms in this state do not have the
assets the assets are held at a higher
level really
okay so if we were to presumably one of
the biggest I mean there's probably a
lot of a lot of arguments for the
current system we have I'm assuming the
biggest one is probably liquidity you
know are we going to you would if you
lock up things that they can't be used
as collateral I'm not saying that we
should be using things as collateral
without the be without the uh the
permission of the of the perceived owner
but pres presumably this could really
drain liquidity from the system is that
that not a potential concern I imagine
maybe the people behind you will will
bring that up they they they will say
this and let me say that the reason I
went to Sweden in
2009 was that I discovered this then and
Sweden and Finland were the only
countries that had not been subverted in
this way they all the G30 countries had
been pushed to dematerialize In This Way
in 19 beginning in 1970 but the way the
swedes did it so they had a
modern uh indirect holding system but
they they used computers which existed
to to have specific identification of
every person to every
security and by going there I was
actually able to move my Swedish
government bonds from here there and
really own them there so it's not true
that you can't have a modern efficient
system that is entirely
electronic but the way it was done here
was to sever sever this direct record
and create this pooled
nature um the other thing is by just
striking these exceptions none of the
plumbing changes this is why this is
actually a very
conservative approach appr it's an
elegant conservative approach because
nothing will change in how the system
operates it will only come into play if
there is insolvency in which case you
want to have made these
changes thank you okay you still have a
question
or U I think I can get the answer by
looking at the video okay all right so
my question is really
simple it says in here banks that are
too big to
fail right banks are too big to
fail and now you're talking about
armagedon so are you saying that
Armageddon this is a yes no answer is
are you saying the Armageddon is the
bank that was too big to fail the
Armageddon is that it did fail that's
what we're fearful
of is that that's yes no is that what
you're trying to say to
us uh I'm not sure what is the armagon
what is the armag the armagon is the
banks that are too big to fail right the
the the Armageddon planning is is that
the the assets will be taken by the
biggest banks great okay representative
burough thank you and thank you for
taking my question just a quick question
I I missed who you represent and why you
came all the way from Sweden I I
represent
myself um I don't represent any entity
this is my work this is what I do um and
I don't uh uh whatever comes from this
book goes to support uh don Grandy's
efforts who who wrote the Bill um so
this is entirely because I um care about
what's going to happen here to all of us
representative
Gibbs thank you Mr chair um I'm confused
by something early on in your testimony
you said that nobody lost money um under
the current system uh with the Leman
Brothers failure but then later on in
your testimony you said that JP Morgan
was allowed by a court to take investors
collateral because JP Morgan was a
creditor in which case the investors
would have lost money so which is
correct yes it's I I made the first
statement because that's what the bank
lobbyists will say is that and they have
that that no one lost money in lit
Brothers this is an analogy for this
let's say you come out of your home in
the morning uh you need to go to work
and your car is gone and 5 years later
your car is is returned by the police
does that mean your car was not
stolen obviously not that's what
happened with I I'm agreeing with you
that's what happened to these very
sophisticated enormously power powerful
investors investment firms they lost the
use of their collateral when they most
needed it and for over five
years uh follow-up question please
further question thank you
um so is what you're saying that
eventually they lost their collateral or
eventually they got it back but there
was a long judicial process well it it
was possible to make recovery because
another even bigger Financial bubble was
blown blown up that allowed that to
happen um so they they did eventually
make recovery but that's the purpose of
that car now ology the car the car is
still stolen the property was stolen
when they needed to when they needed it
most they may have gone out of business
in the interim those firms to have lost
their their capital in that crisis they
might not have even existed five years
later so um I don't does that help to
answer the question that's great thank
um I'm I'm sorry um one one more
followup okay thank you um
so did any company go out of business as
a result I I don't know actually I I I
think there there were a lot of firms
who went out of business but I don't
know about specific firms that had their
collateral taken but um well I won't go
into a story that fa thank you very much
all right so we'll we'll uh I'm sure J
will make sure you know when our
subcommittee's been scheduled okay thank
you thank you
okay uh for the other side of the story
Charles Mooney for the uniform law
commission thank you chair uh good
morning committee my name is Charles
money uh last year I was appointed by
Governor zunu as a uniform law
commissioner for the State of New
Hampshire
uh amendments similar to HB 427 were
presented to several States last
year uh none of them passed and I think
the same result should happen in New
Hampshire uh you've heard Mr
web you know I don't know whether to say
I don't know what to say or I have too
much to say but I will say
and I choose these words carefully
virtually every statement he made about
the operation and characterization of
UCC article 8 was
wrong and I've never been involved in a
debate where we didn't debate based on
policy disagreements and arguments about
instrumental effects of law and the
like and I'm very sad to have to to to
make that and I can't uh dispute all of
them uh but what I would like to do as a
first step and the chair has mentioned
the subcommittee and there's an
opportunity for us really to roll up our
sleeves and get to the nitty-gritty but
what I would like to do today is a bit
of education and and
description uh this is inspired by the
book that was mentioned the great taken
it's a it's a classic conspiracy theory
I won't take my time but I really hope I
get a question about that because I
would love to uh explain how it just
doesn't work
uh so let me talk a little about the the
the background and the intermediated
holding system for Securities I've
distributed a handout exhibit a is just
a diagram of the uh holding system in
the United States and many other
countries depository Trust Company uh
Securities deposit
uh uh is at the top Banks and Brokers
have accounts with it uh and those
participants who have accounts uh have
their customers who are investors some
of their customers are other
intermediaries going down uh uh the
chain this has been a common means for
investors to hold their Securities for
many many years there's nothing uh new
here what has been new is that
since the 1960s the infrastructure has
evolved because there was a near
breakdown in the Securities markets
because of so-called paperwork crunch
they couldn't keep up with the trade so
now at the top the participants at for
every trading day all the trades are
netted out so that every participant
either delivers or receives one amount
for each security and either pays or
receives payment of one amount for all
the trades and this intermediated
holding allows that in the operation of
DTC which is evolved over the years from
starting out as a as an arm of the New
York uh Stock
Exchange
so HP 427 is a proposal to amend article
8 this is a solution in search of a
problem it's an unwise fix for a
non-existing problem that would only
harm investors both
individuals and businesses article 8
deals with transactions and investment
Securities it promotes uniformity and
efficiency and predictability across
state
lines customers do have a property
interest and let's set one thing State
this security entitlement that Mr web
has described
is
everything that investors customers of
uh uh intermediaries had before these
1994 amendments the idea that it was
created by them the term was created but
the security tlement simply describes
what it is that the investor gets a
property right a proportionate property
right and all of the Securities of a
particular type with all other investors
who have accounts with that intermediary
and a bundle of Rights and
duties against the intermediary which is
something that was not spelled out in
previous law there's also more
protection for the property rights than
there was under the previous version of
the article 8 of the uccc and I'm again
prepared to explain in detail how that
is but you're getting the idea this is
complex
uh and uh I I'll do what I can in the in
the brief time I have uh an
intermediary can only pledge these
Securities if customers have an interest
in them subject to very stringent
requirements only with the consent of
the customer nobody takes them customers
exercise their right over their property
interest to transfer them these
proportionate property interests these
Pur pools of Securities have existed for
a long long time long before the uccc
even uh which began work in the 40s and
first promulgated in the 19 uh uh
50s so the proposal is to take 8511
which starts out with the Baseline rule
is a customer has priority over a
secured creditor of the intermediary
that's exhibit B you can see
intermediary
borrow uh and that was something added
in the 1994 amendments it did not exist
before
then then there are two exceptions one
is if there's a loan to the
intermediary that's where the lender
takes control that is the power over the
asset actually essentially takes it
away uh and the other is a loan to a
Clearing Corporation like the deposit R
Trust
Company the DTC and its affili
Affiliates have billions of dollars in
backup lines of credit that would be
jeopardized or eliminated if if these
were to pass this this these lines of
credit back up the settlement process if
some intermediary fails to make sure
every gets performed in time and it also
provides substantial protection against
systemic uh uh risk
now the suggestion was
that the 1994 amendments added these
priorities well they added those
Provisions all right but there are
corresponding Provisions which provide
additional protection for the uh uh
investors consider first a bank that
borrows Banks normally don't use
customer Securities to borrow only
Brokers are allowed to do that and that
to a very very limited uh extent
uh in no Bank insolvency I'm ever aware
of has any customer lost where the bank
was the custodian it's simply a nonissue
although Banks do sometimes borrow with
Securities a secured lender this is
asset based in the Securities
Market they have to be sure they're
first and to tell them they might be
subordinate down the line in insolvency
to a customer which is the only time the
only time collateral matters is not much
soless uh but take where most of us have
our Securities with broker dealers
registered with the SEC members of the
Securities investor Protection
Corporation which provides certain
Protections in the event the broker is
in an
insolvency uh
proceeding what's the priority there
well the priority is that secured
creditors have the priority
the UCC doesn't apply CPA the Securities
investor protection act provides that
priority for these broker
dealers there are some other problems
that will be caused I'll mention however
but this certainly wasn't anything that
was brought about by the 1994 amendments
why is that priority there it's there to
benefit the investors the customers of
the broker
in exhibit two you can see the loan to
the
intermediary
uh customers often want to borrow from
their broker these are often called
margin loans now the proponents have
suggested elsewhere that oh that has
nothing to do with this these priority
rules are loans to the intermediary not
to the customer well a broker dealer is
not like the old Scrooge McDuck sitting
in a room full of coins and bills with
money deciding what to do broker dealers
have to fund their loans they borrow at
favorable rates which allows them to
loan at favorable rates to their
customers that's the only reason we have
that
priority uh other than the fact it's
been the the priority that existed even
before sipa in the
1970s uh going back at least to the
1930s when the Securities Acts were
enacted and changes the bankruptcy
law were made so this priority has
always been
there the idea that until 1994 has
indicated for 400 years I don't know
where that number came from but I've
only been researching in this area for
about 52 years maybe 53
but the idea that somehow before then
there was some rock solid interest in a
specific security is just
ridiculous that hasn't been the way
intermediaries held customer
accounts forever that I know of well
maybe they used to actually have custody
of those things like a safe deposit box
G but certainly not in the modern era uh
the only time a customer would have a
right in a specific security is if it's
actually in the name of the security
written on the
certificate usually that happens when
the broker dealer fails in the few times
they have and they were getting ready to
mail it out to the customer but it's
still in the mail room or still in the
desk so the idea that somehow before
1994 or going way back you had some
different kind of property right is just
wrong I mean the reference to the New
York
fed letter the idea that someone's
hiding that well nobody's going to hide
something that's harmless I mean it's
it's essentially laughable all that said
was in answer to a question
does an investor a customer have a
property right in any specific security
well the deposit trust company has
warehouses some of which are in uh New
Jersey which was mentioned in one of the
earlier uh uh uh hearings certificates
are everywhere customer names are not uh
uh uh on those and of course the answer
was no they have a proportionate
property interest in the Securities of
that type not in any particular security
all the customers would share not only
that not only that for broker
dealers if I've got a security interest
and I'm a customer if I've got a
security entitlement to ABC
shares and the chair has a security
entitlement to XYZ shares and the broker
fails
and there are plenty of ABC shares but
the XYZ Shares are
gone is the chair out of look through
the pure foru that there's a shortfall
here and not there no the chair is not
out of look because under the Securities
investor Protection Corporation all of
the customers of the intermediate the
failed broker
dealer share in the entire group of all
types of
Securities and they take their net
Equity the value they're supposed to
have in their account less the amount
they've borrowed from the broker
and that's their
claim and they have that claim to all of
the Securities not just to the ones so
even if
the private law
UCC provides that you have a property
interest in specific things that would
apply in a bank insolvency or for a
Clearing Corporation but for a broker
dealer under sipa all the customers
share this ensures that customers have a
much much much lower chance of a big
loss and of course under CPA uh cpic
provides protection for investors and
broker dealers for the
retail uh investors up to
$500,000 in loss now that's not 500,000
insecurities that's loss if I've got
five million insecurities in the account
and there's a highly unusual loss of 10%
of the customer Securities are
gone well I'm still fully protected
because my short fall is
$500,000 that's
loss uh I'm happy to provide data and we
could get into this in the subcommittee
meeting on the experience of cpic the
claim that it's underfunded and and uh
couldn't meet its obligations is
unfounded and I think we can explain why
losses have been relatively minimal
there have been relatively very very few
broker dealer uh insolvencies
finally I should mention on these
Protections in exhibits B and
C when a broker
loans when a broker borrows from A
lender and uses customer Securities
which are securities it's allowed to use
because customers have
consented there are a couple of
important
restrictions one
is the borrowings by the broker for
customer
Securities cannot exceed the amount that
the broker has loaned to its
customers so they always offset so the
customers could never lose more from the
bank's borrowings than the customers as
a group uh would lose based on what they
actually owe because the bank can't
borrow more than the customers
owe secondly
as an exhibit see there's a reserve
account when a bank borrows using these
Securities the customers agreed not all
of the customers only a fraction can be
used by the broker when the broker
borrows using that collateral it has to
take what it borrows and put it in a
reserve bank
account now it can offset that in effect
take it out of the account the amount it
has loaned to the
customer so it's borrowed 100 it's
loaned 100 it doesn't have to post
anything but if it borrows
120 and has only loaned 100 to the
customer it has to put 20 in cash
equivalence to the reserve account well
that wouldn't make much sense to borrow
at Market rates and then somehow have to
invest it in a
sterile uh Reserve
account what this ensures is that the
borrowings by the
brokers in effect must be used for the
benefit of the customers to fund these
to fund these
loans well in some the system works
well uh investors are protected there's
simply no need for these amendments they
wouldn't serve any useful purpose they
could only disadvantage both investors
and the markets I will say that if New
Hampshire passed these
amendments in my view I'm not the Bank
lobby but I've been involved in credit
for my entire professional career and
even
before I think it highly unlikely that
there would be loans to
Banks located in New Hampshire except at
a much higher cost if they were were
made for
Brokers uh even though cpit Prov cpic
Pro CPA provides that secured creditors
have
priority I would predict substantial
litigation and risk for banks that they
would Bank lenders they would see if
these passed in state and much less if
if they started passing in more Estates
because because there would be
litigation why well we've never had this
big disparity assuming this amendment
were to pass we would never have had
this big disparity between the rules for
the insolvency rule under
CPA and the private law rules so I can
imagine folks you know trying to argue
oh well the private law overrides we now
have to change it in accordance with
these new amendments to the uccc so uh I
can't go into detail now but I'm happy
to answer any questions or provide any
additional
detail I I think my professor Persona
got away from me but this truly is an
educational opportunity because this is
a complex subject but an important one
so any questions you have I would be
happy to I I hope we can hold it to the
subcommittee representative Walsh has a
question
thank you Mr chair I'll be brief and
thank you for taking my question pardon
my you know lack of financial prowess in
all this I realize it's very deep and
you somewhat touched upon this but we
are Commerce and consumer affairs so if
the proposed legislation protects a
consumer and just if you've already got
a wall with this sippa wouldn't this
just make that wall a little bit thicker
I guess I don't understand what the
major objection is if you could just
simplify for my for my tiny mind a
little bit better the the objection is
the ability to get for my broker to get
credit is a big Advantage for me if I
want to make
loans and the the broker can only
pledge only where consumer consumers and
investors have margin accounts they've
agreed that they can borrow and they've
agreed that the broker can use their
Securities only a portion of them only a
portion of them as collateral and to
tell me my broker now is going to pay
more for credit is not going to help me
plus as I explained through the customer
protection rule uh uh of the
SEC both prongs of it consumers are
protected when their assets are pledged
it's not just a naked pledge so that I
think is the answer second this has been
the lay of the land for decades and
decades it has not caused a problem
there is no risk caused by that the the
Leman example
that didn't involve article 8 in any way
all the retail investors were
protected the only reason some
institutional investors waited five
years is something they now recognize
and they're much more careful but they
had entered into so many transactions of
such
complexity and almost everyone involved
lawsuits of valuing
collateral that the complexity of their
transactions took that long to
litigate uh in any event they might have
lost more if it didn't take so long they
might not have but I I think they know
what they're doing but I I hope that's
an answer just making it more costly for
firms to borrow uh is not any help to uh
Securities account holders
hey
represent thank you for your expertise
and for taking my question so can this
is just agree disagree and then we could
get into it at a subsequent time but do
you agree or disagree with the the
provision that would disallow a
programmable medium of
exchange um essentially prohibiting a
cbdc um as stated in the bill agree
disagree with that
provision I agree with its purpose I
think it needs some drafting but I agree
with the stated purpose to exclude the
cbdcs if that's if that's responsible
thank you responsive okay good great
thank you very much we'll see you soon
enough uh uh as always happens if they
wait long enough another card will
appear
n from the business and industry
Association in opposition to the Bill
thank you Mr chair I will take up
hopefully less than a minute of your
time n Grace the business and industry
Association I won't repeat anything that
was already said um I just want to note
our opposition to uh State changes to
the UCC we think are more appropriate uh
venue is to go to the UCC panel and get
them to make changes and bring that back
to the legislature the point of the UCC
of course is to provide uniform
regulations for businesses across uh as
much of the United States as possible
that ensures that for a small state like
us we have a competitive Advantage
because we know what the regulations are
and businesses know what to expect um so
on this issue and any other one we would
object to change changes at the state
level happy to take any questions if
there are
any fair enough thank you very much
thank you and with that I will close the
hearing on
and if you want to you have a hand out
just pass it
out the used to say the bankers
Association is in opposition to the bill
and with that you certainly will be
there for the subcommittee no matter
what okay all right
Tom you're
on we open the public hearing and House
Bill
406 I see our Deputy you
see what's
that oh oh okay you want to you want to
introduce it okay no let's I so this
case it's the department Bill I just
assume how the department introduced the
bill cut to the
Chase and the deputy's
here are we9 we are now on
46 I apologize for the delay but I'm
sure you guys found that conversation
very stimulating
good morning everyone my name is Aaron
Hennessy I am the deputy secretary of
state and with me is Tom Connelly who is
the director of our corporations
division um we uh had many requests from
several businesses in the state for this
type of legislations to assist them and
I'm going to have Tom go into details
behind that so I would say um yes it was
a request of our office but at the
request of people who file business uh
reg um fings with our
office uh thank you and good morning um
the uh the bill that we have before you
today uh is attempt to address two
specific problems issues that we're
we're facing here with the buiness
registry that are not for they're not
unique to New Hampshire um the first is
company hijacking situations where um
someone will go in and file an annual
report changing the names of the
business owners the business officers
and directors um to uh make it appear as
though they are in charge and therefore
they go to the bank the bank takes a
look at our records and see oh this
person is the president or they're not
manager of that LLC and we use that
public filing as a means to um take
owners to uh to gain control of either
business accounts or to um apply for
loans uh we had a situation with a
business who had a um uh who get in was
filed um put that entity changing the
name of the officers the individual
involved um uh applied for for a uh a
car loan purchased a truck and uh the uh
the business only found out that they
owned this truck when they got the
payment book in the mail 30 days later
um what we're trying to do is when when
a business um it becomes aware that a an
authorized filing has been submitted to
give us the tools to be able to verify
that that that record was indeed
authorized and to be able to remove it
from the public record as soon as
possible if we receive a a sworn a
statement from that from that business
um the second issue we're dealing with
which is another one that's becoming
more frequent is what we call synthetic
entities businesses that are set up to
make look at they appear as though they
are a legitimate business or an existing
business by establishing a similar name
using that same business as street
address and so forth but in reality that
business um is a separate legal any that
doesn't exist um and as a result of that
um are trying to basically trade on the
on the on the on the existing businesses
attributes uh it's you know locasion it
may fool other folks into thinking that
they are actually for example sending a
check or or obtaining an order from a
legitimate business but in reality that
again that business is not a a
legitimate entity um we've had a couple
of situations here recently in New
Hampshire um representative lose Bay who
was our who kind of put as the primary
sponsor of the bill here had a situation
with a constituent in Dover who owned a
restaurant and then a business was
established um with a very similar name
um using that same business address um
they became aware of the of the issue
when um they received in in their mail
uh bank statement from chape bank
showing that a bank account had been
opened up in that name and then
subsequently started to receive uh debit
cards and other other fact that that
they were someone was trading under that
under that name using their address um
the uh the folks filed a filed a uh a
report with the uh the the police
department it's potential situation with
business entity theft but in reality you
see there's not a lot that law
enforcement can do in these situations
we were able to trace the transactions
based on the uh they these entities were
filed electronically they were created
using our using you know our website to
go ahead and and um complete analy
formation submit it to us make payment
and and receive authorization that the
filing had been completed um we trace it
back to a to a um IP address in in in
Brooklyn New York um and found over a
series of time um seven or eight
entities that were created with this
very similar similar format um for
existing businesses around the state um
right now we don't have the tools to
really address this say in terms of the
Authority or Powers available to the
Secretary of State um other than the
Securities regulation group we're not an
enforcement office with respect to
corporations um the business Corporation
act says that basically if it if it if
it's if it uh if it's complete and if
they permit the correct um you know
filing fee and we can index it that
we're required to take it and it has no
um determination whether that that
filing is legal or or illegal or whether
it's authorized or unauthorized what we
like to do is have the the ability to
remove those types of filings um um from
our from our records as H said that
people look to the business registry to
our to our website to validate the
businesses that are are existing and
that the information that they hope they
can rely on is being accurate so we want
to be able to have basically have a way
for us to be able to remove those those
synthetic entities when we become aware
of them but also with benefit of
Technology um we're getting ready this
year to shoot an RSP to replace our
existing system and we know that using
technology we can find ways to address
the issue where people are unable to
successfully know using the anonymity of
the internet be able to um pretend to be
somebody else and to trans file
transactions with us and create entities
that'll be used for nefarious purposes
um the language you have here was
substantially taken from um a
Connecticut bill um our colleague I work
closely with the colleagues from the
corporation of Visions from around New
England um and this was a language that
they successfully passed in the uh state
of Connecticut uh came effective January
1st of this year um I'd be happy to take
you through the bill if if you would
like me to do that or we can wait till
we do that in sub commmittee but yeah
we'll do that committee yeah um so
basically that's that's that's the
intention of the bill that's what we're
trying to accomplish here and be happy
to answer any questions that you might
have about the bill or about these
individual um situations that have
occurred that we're trying to trying to
withdraw address representative Sal has
a question thank you chair for taking my
question my question is when we form the
company we give all kind of information
to the Secretary of State and you guys
verify the data and then give us a uh
authorization to work for any
businessman we have a good standing
certificate which you guys provide so
during that process do you not validate
these
things thank you that that is correct we
do not um folks do not have to present
identification to us when they complete
a form and to file it with us whether
they do it online or in person um so
yeah currently there is no validation
that's the when the business
corporations were previously statutes
were created obviously the the um prior
to the 1970s when you were to form a
business file anything with us the
signatures had to be notorized and
notarization came off of these forms
back in the 80s when we started to
computerize wanted to make it simpler
and easier for folks to be able to
complete electronic transactions and so
with that the the ability the duty to
verify who that individual was um was
removed from the statute So currently we
do not verify who they
are representative baros thank you just
a quick question thanks for taking my
question do you know how prevalent this
is I mean this is really identity fraud
do you know how prevalent it is in New
Hampshire um the the item the situations
which been reported to us so far have
been I'd say probably I'm fully aware of
probably it's happened a couple dozen
times here in the last two
years so um is someone who has some
corporations registered and and a
nonprofit too um I know that the front
in the front end I have to have a login
to be able to get in to go and change
that so did some people somehow were
able to get that person's initial loog
what their login information is or can
somebody can crash the system and get
get in there and then start changing the
the
membership the logins are tied
specifically to a individual user
account they're not tied to the business
entities that they may be filing against
so anyone could create
an a quick start account um and then
file documents against any other other
other entity types right one of the
things that we're envisioning in our in
our our next system is that if a user
just like yourself personally if you
want to lock down your your credit file
means that you can do that with the
credit bureaus when someone forms an LLC
with us if they wanted to lock down
their record provide them with unique
pin they they have to present each time
they follow a document that we provide a
way that we could the annual I'm
thinking in terms of the I have to do it
annually you know correct come January 1
I got my you know notifications used to
be the little card but now we get get
the email notifications and I duly log
in and I and but I never thought realize
that that anybody else could log in and
then get access
to the my the corporate entity that I'm
supposed to be representing other words
is it is not TI when I when I create
that account it doesn't say I'm the only
person who can then change the uh the
board membership it does not oh that's
a you got to fix
that that's a little
scary indicated the fact that said that
the the also the uh um fraud is not been
a dramatic problem as they said the vast
majority of our our businesses are
legitimate they they they attempt to
file prop most folks in fact when they
register file their their inter report
if there's been no changes they're not
required to to log in only if they want
to make changes do they have to actually
log in past year but you every year I
got to log in to pay my my fee um yes I
said if you if you have if you have any
information that you need to change
otherwise if you if you have no changes
to make you can simply um provide your
credit card what what I'm saying is is
that that that my you have my
identification because I'm that personal
log in wouldn't you make sense to that I
be limited to access to be able to
change any of the corporations to the
ones that I am officially registered to
I said that's that's one one scenario
that we're envisioning we could provided
with with our our next system it make my
life easier too because if I just log in
and then pulls up my list then I can by
a Bing b boom and take care of all of
them that I have rather than rather than
you know I unfortunately have several
logins well me to your point being that
there is that is certainly that that's
that's one approach the thing is often
time we find too is that um an attorney
or a Service Company like Legal Zoom
will create your B your business for you
then after the first year you may or may
not still have them as your registered
agent um you may want them to do your
compliance for you you may not um the if
if you're doing a transaction with your
attorney and your the per legal needs to
go in and file an a M that sort of stuff
there in the end there were users who
were who would have a valid reason to go
in and file documents against that
entity so the login doesn't prevent
others um from doing so but we said we
could provate a model where you could
you could control access to that well at
least nothing else is that that I get
notification that somebody else logged
into that
account logged in made a change and they
say did were you the one who did this I
mean Google does it to me all the time
every time I read do a computer or
something like that it it sends me a
notice and say by the way some you know
we just noticed that you had a new
person just a new person logged into
your account yes sir our system does do
that that that for if you someone
someone files that that that an report
filing on your entity if you provided us
with a we call a business notification
email that email is notified that a
filing has filed against that business
okay feel a little
[Laughter]
better okay we'll take it up in
subcommittee oh we do have a question
yes representa Pell so um I'm looking at
enables the Secretary of State to verify
and prevent fraudulent business
formations are you now saying that you
want to require the Secretary of State
to take these um verification they are
the secretary state that's who they are
right but are you go is this a
requirement now going
forward I would just say this is
enabling and and not for every single
transaction that comes through our
department we're not going they don't
they don't have the same relationship
with the Attorney General's office that
most of our departments have so they're
they do everything by Statute so the
statute needs to Clearly say they have
the right to take misinformation down
okay okay whereas most departments would
contact the AG's office and the ag
office could so that's why the um Bill
States on page two in line 15 and 23
they may verify data or may take the
following measures and are not requ Reed
to to do that correct May versus sh
correct yes and and I will say there is
a process currently in law but it's a
very lengthy process where letters have
to be mailed to the address we have to
wait for a return um letter to come to
us from the post office and 60 days Tom
can go into more in the subcommittee
hearing but I got Pony Express
delivering mail to me in ring
so okay great thank you very much all
right we will close the public
hearing oh NCH I'm sorry sorry sorry
sorry sorry okay reopen the public
hearing that gra from the Bia has some
concerns yes Mr chair uh n GRA with Bia
again um I can put my comments in a
letter and email that or an email and
send that out to the committee this
afternoon if that would be easier and
you'll show up to the subcommittee yes
and that's I think at this point what
we're asking for because we have a
number of questions with the language of
this bill uh we certainly don't object
to the point let's take care of the Bad
actors but at the same time um just
based on how it's drafted we have a
number of questions you got two weeks to
work with Tom and get it figured out I
got it I'll give my people the deadline
all right thank you thank you okay now
I'll close the public
hearing
406 and so what are we we're half an
hour behind schedule okay so um let's
try to be back here by by
1:30
e
e e
you
okay all right open up the public
hearing on
Andes again is here is
here and you're the prime right yeah the
only all right let's do
it you you I have a here right yeah 27
be there we go Jack
flig Mason when did you move to
Mason no you to look
professional you you have
to you got
to things have changed since you
left you're very high-tech now and I and
all I can say is and caution you is to
be aware that everything you say or do
is going to be preserved Forever on
YouTube
right thank you Mr
chair thank the committee MERS for
taking my bill under advisement for the
record I think I represent the largest
florial in the state of New Hampshire
it's it consists of the towns of Hollis
Brookline Mason and Greenville no
there's been there's more it's almost
it's almost the same size of our Senator
except it your Senator includes ringe
and part of nashille so it's a big
District yes um I'm presenting uh House
Bill uh
275 and Mr chairman you might remember a
conversation act like the mic is is my
friend in your mouth yes
no so you'll remember a number of years
ago we spoke about insurance companies
uh requiring healthc care providers to
have additional training and this is
training over and above what their uh
colleges and um um their what would be
internships it was board certified was
the the magic word they are through the
oplc be board certified right and the
oplc also gives them their licenses so
what happened was um I had a dentist
that I had through an Anthem policy of
Medicare
Advantage and that insurance company
told my dentist that um he can't be
certified with them until he has his
entire staff to have lgbtq plus training
so in other words the teeth of that
group is different than all of ours I
guess I have no idea but um he refused
because he had four
locations so the cost would have been
very
prohibitive and I know Mr chairman how
much you hate putting costs back to the
insurance companies because the
insurance companies always hit the
insured with it makes sense that's by
law under Obamacare okay however when
they want something and it's not
required for the certification or the
licensing or the approval of the healthc
care provider I thought it' be
reasonable that they pay for it and
spread the cost of that requirement over
the entire country instead of maybe the
people in the state of New Hampshire
because if they didn't get reimbursed
and did do the program that cost would
be bored by the the the patient or um if
they um they didn't do it they would
have to go to a different dentist doctor
or whatever healthc care provider so it
really put the the consumer in a in a
conundrum you can not go to and go to
different doctor dentist who have got a
lot of faith in or you can get a
different insurance company I guess or
you can pay for the insurance in the
with the dentist doctor that you have
faith in so I thought that was wrong
because ultimately is it's the insurance
company that's making these requests or
demands on the healthc care provider and
I feel that they should pay for it now a
couple things was is when when I first
approached this with you Mr chairman I
couldn't find where in law I could put
this but thank goodness for the O OS
they found this Managed Care provision
which is what most hmos are and it fit
right in there
perfectly so I also want to uh talk
about the fiscal note here which when I
read it I was like going did they really
write this because they talk about first
of all they avoid the uh oplc as the uh
licensing of healthc care providers and
it's almost like they're putting the
demand on the insurance companies and
it's the actually the other way around
is the insurance companies put the
demands on the healthcare provider and
they have no licensing provision they
have the certification provision as as
far as being the approved healthc care
provider but they have nothing to do
with the state approval as it relates to
their
licensing so I was thinking well they
didn't do a lot of research on that one
because I talked to a number of
Physicians even remember Joe
Hannah yeah he he was just downstairs at
a marijuana uh not a
surprise and I asked him and he
confirmed that the licensing is D done
by the certified body in the state and
really the insurance company is just and
and again again I'm I'm using a little
um stretch here but I think if they can
approve the price of the service you'll
get approved unless you have some type
of bad history but like malpractice and
things like that so with that I'm I I I
will gladly accept your hurdles thrown
at
me represent Spears has a
question the example that you use was
Medicare Advantage yes mhm uh I don't
think we have that much control over
Medicare
Advantage I mean we can't it's not like
we can legislate against those guys do
you have any example of an insurance
company within the state that's under
the control of the state well my policy
and thank you for your question my
policy happened to be through the the
plan and I and I didn't send um I don't
think a a complaint to them maybe I did
I'm not sure in typical fashion I
probably didn't hear anything from
Anthem but um the um the reality is if
they have to comply with the state law
because they're licensed in the state of
New Hampshire so um and I know I know
what you're saying it's because I have a
background in insurance too but if the
policy is paid for by Medicare then I
think it's a little different than the
the the the the laws within the state in
which they do business
uh this
420j is uh as far as I know that is the
small
employer fully insured it does not
include um Medicare supplemental it's
420j is our Managed Care statute so it
only technically as far as I know but we
we have some people from well when you
put it might know better than I do but
when you put it into to a
subcommittee which hopefully won't be
next week because I won't be here but
I'll gladly it will have to be two weeks
from now that' be wonderful I'll be more
than happy to do whatever research is on
that and you bring up a good point
representative I I I know I have
contacted uh was it CPM uh CMS yes on
other other issues I'm not sure if it
dealt with Anthem or not but I'm glad
that it's being recorded forever and
ever
forever representative am Mr chair thank
you representative for your testimony um
I'm trying to wrap my head around the
concept of this bill it sounds like this
could be considered an unfunded mandate
from the insurance companies onto the
providers is that a correct loose
understanding of it high level yeah I
thank you for the question I I I didn't
really think about that but yeah I guess
if if they want to it's a pay for play
right if you if you pay then you
continue doing business with I would
imagine the largest insurer of the state
so yeah it would be pay or play or it
would be uh unfunded
yep representative
Bros thank you for taking my question I
I first of all I want to make sure I
understood you you seem to be saying
that credentialing uh these Insurance
these insurance companies is a quick
thing is that is that what you implied
no I'm just saying is they're asking for
training of these the physicians in this
case a dentist that isn't part of the
certification to become a dentist or a
doctor in the state of New Hampshire and
they want the the professional to pay
for it and I'm just saying is if they
want it that if the insurance companies
want this type of training from the
doctor that's not required for the
licensing then uh they should pay for it
thanks wasn't there a question over
here so uh we do have other people going
to come in but um in
my I guess my my little experience
here this what this was SE was about
was a insurance
company
um had had uh maybe rejected someone to
be in their
network uh and
um because the
insurance company required had certain
requirements and it says uh
solely okay said solely because of their
meet the health carers credential
verification
standards what you were describing as a
training course not really a ver you
know a certification but this was go
back to where I was saying being board
certified and this is about getting in
the network Okay so so I want you to
first know is that not everybody every
healthc care provider can get into a
network okay correct y that they the the
healthc care provider the the insurance
company can
decide who how many people or whether
they have enough people in their Network
and therefore met the uh Network
standard so they that they had were had
enough people in the network can I
respond to that Mr chairman sure most of
the time in talking to other you know
Health Care Professionals the basis is
on money in other words we will do the
business we'll cover the insurance at x
amount of dollars and that covers you
know what the insurance companies want
to pay so and in this case too the
example that I gave you was not really
an issue on training it was their social
score their social Equity score on you
know their ESG score we got we have that
as a separate Bill talk about so in this
case this case the issue because you
were talking about money and and you're
absolutely right it is about money uh we
have uh we have in this committee we
have the ambulance issue oh God and the
ambulance issue is that the ambulance
providers refuse to sign a contract
because they want to back bill they want
to get all their money they don't want
to take that lower amount that that's
agreed upon so it is true that an
insurance company says okay it's all
about the money you say this is what we
want you to do and you have to decide
whether you're willing to accept that or
you decide that you don't want to be a
provider for them right which I've
always heard that was the reason why
most
dentists didn't do too much
uh your network but most denst it's all
about Delta dentle correct yeah okay but
in this case the fact that you dropped
in this sentence into that statute it's
a little it it's it does it doesn't
really flow normally it's not really
they're like two different subjects um
in terms of paying
for those certification paying for what
no that's there's no reason why an
insurance company would pay
for standards or certifications or
justifications the issue would be
normally you would say is that that you
that they didn't offer you a contract
they didn't offer do business with him
because U of his
credentialing but CR but taking having
this uh back this course and having his
employees take that course that
doesn't it's not credentialing anyways
okay well so what I do want to say is
because I always like to take this as an
opportunity to educate people about
premiums about premiums so premiums
thanks to Obamacare or Affordable Care
Act premiums are are the they're are
absolutely governed by what the
insurance company pays
out so if if a pay a provider
anything that goes into the basis which
they do a three-year ruling average
correct and that will determine the
premium and if there if there are less
claims then there's a refund given to
the insur no that's that's old news
there's no refunds anymore I got one
right now we're talking about how they
how they set the premiums now what would
be interested is is to say is oh no this
should be an obligation of the of the
remaining 10% which is what the manag
care company has for their profit you
know profits and marketing and
advertising and okay and and paying for
their employees and the salaries for
their CEOs but which it this it I have
no idea what this would go but I just
wanted to say is this is totally
disjointed in where it's located in the
statute um I stand corrected because we
Rely Upon Our faithful OS people to do
it I think they found looked and they
thought it would be a good place to put
it nice place to put it let me also add
too to the comment that you had
um businesses don't like to tell other
businesses how to run their
business in other words um let's use an
example of say the insurance company
said that they had to be trained on a
certain type of Medical Care before they
could be approved well then they find
out that the medical care that they're
telling them to learn about and do
causes more harm than
good the defense the doctor could have
was well the insurance company told us
to do it and they wouldn't certify us
until they did it in other words there's
some liability that when someone tells
somebody to do something is inherent
liability I've never heard of that
before that an insurance company would
tell somebody what to do that well I
just cited you one no this is this
is this is I Mr chair can I just would
you
believe okay let's say they tell
somebody they have to have some certain
kind of training I don't see it as being
um a potential harm to a to a patient
because they have to have hospital
privileges to do certain things they're
not going to just be allowed to do
whatever you know what ever they have to
be privileged to do it and that's goes
through their credential L from the
hospital side correct there's no doubt
about it but but they they all also
suggest another drug but they will
suggest it if you're on a prescription
but they won't demand it because they
don't know the entire patient history so
I'm just saying is yeah but the the the
the the healthc care provider has to
have some latitude but this the example
that I gave where they told them that
they needed this training which had no
bearing on the service they were
providing um had you know the doctor or
the healthcare provider would have to
have the burden of paying for four
offices to get that training someone's
got to pay for that but I was responding
to you're saying that it could be
dangerous to the patient and and I don't
see that at
all thank you oh well we have more
questions represent
Teresa so I think uh uh thank thank you
chairman for letting me ask the question
and thanks for taking a question
so I guess based on we had most of the
times uh the insurance company and the
provider when they don't agree on free
structure that's the reason they reject
now do you based on what you have
presented have you seen a lot of uh
instances where the insurance companies
talks about uh some training or
processes to be followed besides the
licensing requirement by the state and
based on that there turning down the
provider I'm just understand that what
actually prompted you to bring this well
thank you for the question um well I've
had firsthand experience in this one
instance where they were asking for what
I felt was ridiculous training uh
because like I said the Chairman's teeth
and my teeth are all made by the same
material and we should probably have the
same number although probably lost a few
myself but um it it really had no
bearing on the services to be provided
and I wanted to make sure that it didn't
happen to anybody else and better yet is
if they wanted to do something um for
the health care provider that wouldn't
be in the normal scope of things um then
it shouldn't be shouldn't be asked or if
they want it they should pay for it
follow the question you mean I follow
up so I mean that's one instance my
question was more like have you seen
many instances of this and can you be
more specific what kind of training
meanings uh they ask and they reject
based on that Provider Services well the
only time you'll hear about it is when
the doctor is denied what would you call
it the refus refuse certification or
whatever okay so in my case because of
my background too um they shared it with
me and they shared me why and uh I I
thought that was unacceptable now my
primary care physician is part of the St
Joseph's system and right now St
Joseph's battle with Anthem and they're
not willing to pay them but I don't know
the specific details of that but I do
know that they had three times they went
to get uh adjustments to their pay scale
and they've been denied but other
hospitals were only denied after twice
so yeah there's only so much you can get
from these healthc Care Professionals
because you don't want to get they don't
want to share the the problems in the
back room but in this case they did and
I thought it was totally unacceptable
that that's my healthcare provider had
to take that special training which had
no bearing on my teeth okay and have to
pay for it
themselves okay represent
Gibbs thank you Mr chair um the training
that you referred to that your dentist
was being told he had to uh provide for
his employees uh that wouldn't actually
be a certification but it would be a
program um under the language uh in your
bill wouldn't that be correct that's
what I'm trying to get yeah but the
chairman tells me it's not in the right
place so in the sub when the
subcommittee meets I'll try to find the
right place and we'll make that change
but yes it would be a program it would a
training program sure yeah thank you
yeah thank you very much it's always
great to see you Mr chairman always a
pleasure to seeing you
jack okay the chair will calling
Michelle Heen from the the Hampshire
insurance department who takes no
position on the bill
good afternoon for the record my name is
Michelle Heaton I'm the director of Life
and Health at the New Hampshire
insurance department um we take no
position on this bill but we just like
to um highlight some of the concerns I
think you guys have already touched on a
lot of the issues but um the concern we
see is with the broad language in which
this is written um when you say any
additional program or certification that
is very Broad and I think could have a
lot of unintended consequences that
could be all different kinds of program
and certifications that are required um
across the healthc care system so um
generally um our Managed Care laws do
not set some very loose parameters about
what needs to be in the credentialing
process like the the provider needs to
be licensed and there's certain on
consumer protections that need to go in
the contract but other than that usually
carriers um it is their prerogative who
they want to contract with and have part
of their Network so that's why in doing
our fiscal note um given the broad
language we have um it's hard to
quantify what type of ramifications this
would have but it would likely increase
premiums because there would be
additional costs that carriers would
have to absorb an additional
administrative burden so I'm happy to
answer any
questions representative
spear in the small group and large group
fully insured Market which is what we
usually handle not
Medicare in that group have you ever
seen a complaint of this kind in the
group that we actually can issue laws
about no I mean we routinely get um
inquiries and complaint about
credentialing generally but never about
having to take any specific type of
course or training as a barrier to
credentialing just a follow on on that
forther question may
inquire would is there any place in our
laws and of course I don't know them all
but in your case you probably
do uh where we would be able to control
Medicare in this in this particular case
no no so we would have nothing to do
with this anyway yeah if we're talking
Medicare Advantage um market and the
products that were um previously being
reference we have no regulatory
authority over that whatsoever um and I
know there's mention of oplc oplc sets
licensing requirements so I don't know
that if it's not a licensing requirement
I don't know that that would be an
appropriate place and again I'm not sure
who is going to be responsible for
paying for this if it's if it's a
carrier requirement it would make sense
for it to be an insurance I I guess but
um we would suggest having um a
much clearly def much more clearly
defined um definition as to what exactly
what types of programs or certifications
we're talking about and that again would
um inhibit the carrier's ability to
contract with whoever they please which
is um kind of a key portion of
credentialing thank you very much
sheos no she was just giving information
okay yeah
info okay so Sabrina you're the
uh the one offering up the
opposition but I do want to know from
Paula how long this law has been on the
books this
original because we both been around
long enough we must this must have
happened happened under our watch I just
don't remember it uh thank you chairman
hunt my name is Sabrina Dunlap I'm
director of government relations for
Anthem I'll be brief um I will say when
we first saw this bill we were sort of
befuddled and confused about what it was
trying to get at I repeat the concerns
the insurance department already flagged
um I do just want to note since I think
anthem's name was invoked in sort of a
disparaging way that um representative
planning and did reach out to me in
December of 2022 about this issue
involved a third-party administrator who
I I think Anthem must use in the
Medicare Advantage space which is way
outside of my realm because it is a
federal program nonetheless I wanted to
be helpful and so I reached out to this
third party administrator who's not
Anthem and I inquired about a compliance
program that they had they told me it
was required by federal law and they
said we're obligated to Downstream the
requirements for cultural and linguistic
competency training to our staff and by
extension our contracted providers under
a certain federal code the material
includes communication tips and best
practices for servicing a diverse
membership based on race ethnicity
religion sex gender Etc so this was
something this third-party non- Anthem
entity was doing as they were required
to by CMS I provided that information to
representative Flanigan on December 23rd
2022 so I just wanted to clarify that we
had had that conversation um so I'm
happy to take any questions um and thank
you for the opportunity to speak
okay you really want really quick really
quick how do you keep notes about stuff
like that and how are you able to find
it thank you for the question because it
can be helpful to pull up receipts when
I need them so thank
you okay we close the public hearing
this bill will go to
subcommittee and we'll be dealt with
you uh pay attention to the calendar and
A or B you will get notice
from the staff when we we do it so
figure will be figure another two
weeks yes thank you
okay mov right ahead
let's take up house build
241 and this one we have a lot more
people interested in in participating in
we'll start out with the prime sponsor
representa
Nagel
V
yes you're
on I assume they told you that when
you're oh that's
nice we are all right um I'm honored to
uh present house
20 uh 241 from 2025 here we go again
thank you for the opportunity to do this
um this bill has been the work over at
least 10 years of multiple people from
all over the state the country
representing multiple
stakeholders um working together even
though some of us behind me May oppose
me we've always work together and
hopefully we can come to a solution on
what's a difficult problem my name name
is Dave Nagel I represent the town of
gilmington um Guilford and a little bit
of Laconia um that's not why I'm here
I'm here because I'm a doctor I've
worked with um people with complex
disability my entire career pain is one
of those disabilities I've been involved
in Pain Care policy in this state for
over 30 years um and I also advocated
for people with pain for pretty much
that entire time this is my book some of
which will'll be talking talking about I
was honored this book was a catharsis
because I was angry about how we deal
with the issue of pain in this country
it was never meant to be anything more
than that I was told that this was a
Bible for people in pain so we published
it and this book is now sold all over
the world there are chapters on here
that on issues that we will be
discussing today
um I also um want to say that I
represent the 66 million Americans who
suffer from chronic pain the 1.5 million
in hospice and paliative care every year
the 50 million who will have a surgery
every year and the unknown tens of
millions um who will have a moderate to
severe pain from an acute injury one of
the groups that I do not represent
directly but I'm very proud of are the
veterans of our country the incidence of
chronic pain and and uh combat veterans
is
60% you would you need to know that the
VA actually provides all the services
we're going to be talking today in a
comprehensive integrative way the
Department of Defense does the same
thing if you get injured on the
battlefield you will get Battlefield
acupuncture which is something that you
need to know about so in some if you
were in the we also found out in our
work with my other integrative Pain Care
committee that um hospice provides all
these services but paliative care
patients cannot get them so if you are
near death or you were in combat or
you're a veteran you can get access to
these services that we'll be talking
about today but if you're anybody else
you have
limitations um one of uh I also did you
talk about the fiscal note the the note
that was in it was we haven't talked
about anything about this just the
fiscal note that I saw is inaccurate um
it it actually refers to last year's
bill or two years ago's bill so um we
can talk about that later um one of my
other roles is I got asked to develop a
pain care policy for the NFL and um that
was a fun thing nobody had ever done
that before for elite athletes and I was
excited to do it this is what we came up
with but um as the process of doing that
I interviewed hundreds of professional
athletes and the one thing that's true
about every professional athlete is at
some point they retire when they retire
they have to live with what they've done
to their body through the time that they
were an athlete so one of the players
that I worked with um who was kind of
symbolic um he was a gentleman that
played in the NF for 17 years was lucky
enough in his 17th year to win a Super
Bowl um had 17 surgeries one per year um
and had chronic pain but while he was a
player he was able to access a variety
of therapies that were talking about
specifically Chiropractic acupuncture
massage mindfulness things like that
that are pretty standard basic therapies
for pain and he was able to utilize all
these therapies and restorative I mean
they all exercise which is really
important he was able to utilize all
these things and control his pain
despite 17 years of being you know an
athlete in a pretty rugous
sport what he told me was that the oh
God what he told me was that the minute
that he retired and went to the private
sector he didn't have access to any of
that stuff and the soon as that happened
at least not in a meaningful way and the
minute that happened all of the sudden
is he's got a peace meal everything
together he was not like an elite player
he was not a bubble player he was
somewhere in between he made a good
amount of money but not you know a lot
and so all of a sudden he has to figure
out how he's going to pay for this or
not and what he told me and what we
found out from interviewing athlete
after athlete after athlete is that they
frequently turn to the bar room to deal
with their pain alcoholism is very
common in retired athletes and that's
what he did um the new rage is cannabis
and I know cannabis is the you know the
next best thing for everybody which is
totally another story but anyways a lot
of athletes now are using cannabis for
that purpose which is not necessarily a
good thing when we think we have much
better ways to deal with this problem
this problem doesn't just exist in
professional sports it also exists in
the community and that's what we're
talking about today um to address this
lack of access there's a couple studies
that have been done under great taxpayer
expense that have all come to the same
recommendation this is you have to read
this by tomorrow but this is the
national pain strategy from what 2014 or
something 16 yeah um Cindy's a genius
back there she'll talk to you later um
the first CDC report on um opioid
prescribing from
2016 um this is a report from the
international Olympic Committee looking
at the same issue um um Miss Steinberg
will be talking to you later was one of
the authors of the Health and Human
Services best practice practices on pain
management report released in
2019 and then the CDC report on opioid
prescribing in
20122 what all these things have in
common is one thing they say number one
we do a rotten job of managing pain in
this country number two what we do it's
not cost effective at all and number
three it we must provide access to a
number of these therapies alternative
therapies or whatever and that is the
conclusion from all these studies at the
federal level so it's important
um if the VA can do it and the dod can
do it the question then becomes how can
we do it and the NFL can do it too
although they make more money than we do
um the purpose of this bill was
basically to resolve this issue um when
you look through the bill there's three
parts to the bill the first part is a
preamble and I would ask that you read
that um it basically gives why this bill
is important um we are harming people
with with our failure to treat people in
pain we have a suicide watch that we
maintain it's become significantly worse
since the opioid crisis because now
patients can't get access to opioids so
they have to go to other things and
everybody's saying you need this you
need that you need this Chiropractic
acupuncture massage whatever but then we
don't provide it in any meaningful way
so all of the sudden they're left in
limbo and they go to the streets to get
their pain managed and that's not very
often a good thing um the second part of
the Bill lists a series of interventions
and this is the most fun part of this
bill for me because we work with the
insurers to come up with this
list one of the conclusions that we made
is that any any service to be provided
needed to be provided by a licensed
provider using reasonable evidence base
so there is decent evidence base on
acupuncture the medical acupuncture
prati um evidence project lists
117 um um medical indications for
acupuncture that have evidence um the
second part is chiropractic Amy
Goldstein from the alliance to advance
comprehensive integrative pain
management delivered a report to our
integrative Pain Care Committee in which
she outlined um the Chiropractic is
actually the most coste effective way of
dealing with acute back pain guess who's
the least effective cost effective spine
surgeon guess to where most patients go
spine surgeon makes absolutely no sense
but that is what happens in prac
practice um and then the third thing is
that it's in section five of each of the
there's two different Parts Group and
accidental insurance they're basically
the same thing but Roman numeral 5 I
think is really poorly worded I'd be
happy to work with you on it um I've
never been very comfortable but the
point of that is this I'm very concerned
about the way we use evidence base and
defining what we're going to pay for so
for example um the the bar is very
different for an alternative therapy
than is for a quote allopathic therapy
for example there is virtually no
evidence to support the use of pedical
screw fixation and spine surgery for
anything the morbidity after that
procedure is tragic the outcomes are not
tremendously good it doesn't mean that
nobody does well but the surgery is done
way too often Without Really sufficient
indications and that the alome data
stinks but we pay for that at the same
point we have really good evidence to
support Chiropractic for acut to back
pain cognitive behavioral therapy is a
psychological therapy which really
should be doing in almost everybody with
you know evolving chronic pain to
chronic pain and we have good evidence
for those but we don't pay for them and
I want to give you one example I am an
acupuncturist I basically retired from
that the minute I helped create the
medical acupuncture Practice Act and I
we allowed non-physicians to do it um I
have one patient I've treated for 30
years on a monthly basis her cumulative
bill over 30 years is less than the cost
of one spine surgery and that's making
the Assumption your medical care stops
after that spine surgery it continues so
I wanted to create language that would
mandate I'm sorry about using the word
mandate a Level Playing Field in how we
apply evidence base I know that's a
dirty word but I said it um anyways I
think that's almost everything I just
want to conclude with one one thing
anybody here was a
parent anybody ever spanked their kid I
always had a oh yeah you're not going to
admit it publicly I know so um I I had a
three strike rule with my kids you know
you're you're you're admonished once if
you don't do it you're admonished a
little louder the third time is a quick
smack on the butt right we've been here
a lot to talk about this issue and I you
know not to say anything negative about
my insurance friends but it's time that
we really need to start acting on
creating cost-effective integrative care
and we're not doing it and this is an
opportunity it's a template to do it
that I want to work with you on and so
if this is a third strike and a Pat in
the butt that's fine with me um and one
last thing so I sorry always one last
thing last year I brought you a bill on
prior authorization reform that we all
worked on together right we had a
wonderful time um and and it was a great
experience and and the best part about
it is when we sat down um our bill when
taken in uh with Federal legislation the
Congressional budget office which I know
is never wrong said that we would save
$15 billion per year in terms of health
care cost by doing that I think I'm
pretty sure and and my friend back there
will will give you more data on this
that we will save money doing this and
we will also have less morbidity maybe
less mortality at the same time any
questions okay representative
s thank you for coming in taking my
question uh I'm just curious I mean I
didn't I don't think it would be in here
but you cite a lot of things and how
this would be all cost effective but is
there is there good estimates like you
know because it
might and be clear like even if costs go
up doesn't doesn't mean we shouldn't
cover something but it it certainly is
possible that cost overall could go up
if suddenly people are getting a massive
amount of something that they couldn't
get before doesn't mean they shouldn't
get it and maybe we should expand that
but I'm just kind of curious if we're
spending a million dollars a year on
treating chronic pain and and we open up
these things does that million dollars
go to 900,000 or does it now double
because double the patients are getting
care I think you get my point or my
question yeah no it's an awesome
question um I think there's a number of
different ways to answer that um you
know the last number that was given at
the cost of chronic pain per year was
from about probably 15 years ago was
$650 billion dollars a year chronic pain
cost this country so it's not a trivial
number and it's really important that we
become substantially more efficient with
that when we designed this bill the
reason why we limit it to 12 was because
of that like if you go to the VA and you
get treated they don't limit it to 12
you know you get what you need and you
know it's obviously a different setting
than than you know the medical world is
but but that is why we limited it to 12
the third thing is there's a challenge
that I've delivered to my friends back
there on several times I go you know we
have a uh an epidemic of pills and
procedures that are very expensive I'm
an Interventional spine specialist God
only knows what that means but it means
I use long needles to put into people's
spines to deliver
cortisone um I've never sat down and
figured out how many different
procedures we do um but they're all very
expensive and what's they all share in
common is there's no evidence to support
any of them and so but we pay for that
and then surgeries I already gave you an
example of of a surgery that we know
doesn't work in fact the only surgical
intervention for pain that we have any
clear evidence that it works without
some of the oncology things that we do
is um um s uh just
um uh disc decompression for herniated
disc that has good medium to short-term
outcome data but after two to four years
you're kind of back where you were it's
not a cure in other words
so my belief is and and this is the way
we do everything in in medicine or we
should be doing is we start superficial
and inexpensive and if that's not
working we migrate up to these other
things and but the problem is if you
don't pay for these things first you
accelerate the migration to the
expensive stuff so to some extent the
cost savings are theoretical but I will
tell you we I'm sorry to bring somebody
from the VA to talk about it because a
couple years ago we did and they did
find that this is a lot cheaper for them
to do it this way and patient
satisfactions dramatically
better repres
buros thank you for taking my question
um do you have um data on the efficacy
of all of the all of the um
methodologies that you have in the bill
um I can get there's yes there's a
wealth of it to be honest it's in all
the okay in in in the um footnotes of
all of these things here but we can get
that to you um Cindy Cindy's back there
Amy they're my two best friends Amy
Goldstein uh if you want um she gave us
a wonderful presentation Amy runs the
alliance to advance comprehensive inte
creative pain management which is a
92 stake there's 92 types of stakeholder
groups that look at this um to try to
deal with the issue that we're dealing
with now and she gave us a presentation
that has a lot of that data that's where
we got the data about the
Chiropractic um the acupuncture evidence
project I can give you the um the link
for that um massage is a little bit more
tenuous in terms of getting the data for
that we're going to have some psych
folks talking to you later that can
probably give you that data better than
I can but it's also in here thank you so
if if you want I I can give you all
these references I don't you sure I just
wanted to know that you've looked at all
of these yeah yeah yeah okay there's
only two people in the world that have
read these entire things and they're
both in this room so I won't be one of
them but thank you
represent thank you Mr chair thank you
representative Nel for your testimony um
I'm just trying to understand the bill
maybe there's a simple explanation for
this I'm trying to find the limiting
factor on the mandate so we're trying to
mandate these modalities what's the
limiting factor and when I when I see
page two line one that section there I
see including but not limited
to uh in all three of those sections and
in the first one says and or other
meditation training support groups and
pain education so how what's the
limiting factor on what what is being
mandated good question
um I think we I was actually I knew you
were going to ask that question and I
actually looked at that this morning and
I think that we need to work on that a
because there needs to be some limits to
that I you know first of all our goal
when we WR wrote these things up was
that it had to be provided by a licensed
provider some of these things here are
not so um like for example you know if
it's something that a psychologist uses
as part of their training then that's
what we would want to include in that
for example they use mindfulness use
cognitive behavioral therapy those these
are all tools they use meditation they
use but I think we need to specify in
that section that it be provided by a
licensed provider in this case it'll be
a
psychologist does that help yes thank
you yeah thank you for pointing that out
because I was looking at this morning
and I totally agree with you that needs
to be firmed
up r s thank you chair for taking my
question um my question is like we are
giving the 12 visits we are basically
thinking about in the bill how the
patient might get used to it and then
they need more how we are going to
control that because it is becoming a
factor with the medical professional as
well as the patient how they push it and
how they how the doctors uses it because
there will be a lot of la la land where
it can go in a different
directions I will not argue that that's
a challenge my goal in pain management
is to give a patient the skills they
need to manage their pain on their own
which we really don't do a very good job
on so that would imply that there's a
finite amount of therapy what that the
problem is is that what does that mean
we use a patient centered approach um
like I had one guy come in and after one
visit he knew how to manage his pain you
know and he's going to have pain forever
and he with one visit we were done I was
like wow you know for other patients
it's 13 years you know and and it's it's
an adaptation process that people vary
in so whatever we do needs to be
adaptive but I do get there needs to be
limits at some point
um I I should give this example but I I
had a patient with spinal cord injury
that's got chronic pain and obviously
being quadriplegic is kind of a tough
thing to adapt to um took her 13 years
to realize this was the rest the way the
rest of her life was going to be um
and then it becomes difficult do I not
treat your pain in a self-managed
approach for 12 years because I've put
an arbitrary limit on one that's where
it gets hard my world is I I always work
with patients and I stay with them I
don't like to abandon patients and
unfortunately taking this job I
functionally did but um um I like this
job too but
um it's a challenge and I think you know
we've talked about a work group to sit
down and that's an issue that we have to
come to some conclusion about but I just
don't like abandoning people just
because they don't follow a timeline
so do that
help okay oh representative Sullivan
again yeah um thanks for my second
question um so you you just said to him
and you said it earlier that we don't do
a a good job in teaching patients how to
manage their pain and managing pain in
general I'm just curious what is the
definition of a good job like is there a
country that does it a culture that's
done it is there something we've done
historical that we've forgotten like is
like how do you define it seems a bit
nebulous I'm glad you asked that that's
a really great question so um the nicest
you know I'm not I don't do acupuncture
anymore for the most part but the best
part about it is I got to look at
Eastern cultures ways of doing things
and in in American culture we tend to be
very myopic so we will look at pill here
surgery there therapy here it's not
integrated and that's just the way we do
things and I'm not totally sure why but
that is it's it's very linear you know
we're in Asian cultures things are a
little bit more circular so we look at
Asian medicine as acupuncture well
that's not true what what what Eastern
medicine is is a combination of uh a
restorative thing like an a martial art
for example a mindfulness thing like
meditation or like Tai Chi chiong or
they're movement things but they're also
meditation or mindfulness things herbal
things as a medication and then needles
as an AC as acupuncture so they use all
four things together and what we find is
that when you use Eastern models of in
an integrative way like that is that
people adapt a lot more quickly and and
and come to um a self-realization that
this is where things are at um a lot
quicker one of the bigger problems that
we have this country I think is that um
it's all PR are like in in healthcare
we're watch every drug commercial on TV
you take this drug and you're cured I
listen to seven hours of testimony on
cannabis yesterday and had to scratch my
head oh yeah cannabis is a cure for
everything I mean that's the way we look
at things and it's just not the right
way to look at things we we promise
something we can't deliver so the minute
we stop doing that and we say this is
where you are let's work on from here
and then people will go through an
adaptation process that's variable from
Patient to Patient in terms of how time
that like I mean some patients I I'm
with for like a couple weeks and they're
F I already said that but like and then
other patients it's takes a lot longer
there are patients here that can share
their stories with you a lot better than
I can
um represent a
POS thank you Mr chair would you believe
about in 2018 I had been through a car
accident um in 2013 and I went to four
different surgeons and they all wanted
to do an operation and I was always
nervous about it and held it back and
the last surgeon I saw they told me if I
had a slip and fall or another car
accident I would be permanently a par
paraplegic and I was going down to the
bank to pick up a check and I heard a
gentleman speaking on on uh NPR talking
about pain I bought that book oh my God
I went to that doctor and uh I think I
had one or two years of a just a few um
injections and I have never had a
problem since so I thank you very much
you changed my life wow really you
didn't know I staged this did
you didn't wow um thank you for just
sharing that with me would you believe
that I have two degenerative knees of
biceps tendon rupture herniated disc in
my neck and carpal tunel on both hands
and I put 4,500 miles on my bike last
year and I've never had surgery for any
of it because I use non I don't even
take pills for my stuff so I mean I try
to practice what I preach and I think it
and I don't cost the system anything by
doing
that except my wife cuz she's nervous
cuz I don't wear helmet on my bike but
anyways representative Gibbs let me yeah
thank you Mr chair um please excuse my
lack of medical knowledge but um I'm not
sure um what you mean by teaching people
to manage their pain um does that mean
that you're teaching them essentially to
accept that they'll be in pain for the
rest of their lives and how to deal with
it or is it finding a way to actually
stop the pain that is an awesome
question
so when we wrote the NFL guide that's
the entire first section is to teach
people about how to manage their pain um
no I mean it's a patient everything's
patient centered there's some patients I
have that elimination eliminating their
pain is is reasonable goal um and and
you know when you meet people on day one
you don't necessarily know who they're
going to be um assuming you've seen them
on day one but in other patients you
know this is going to be an issue what
um I can't get rid of your pain but
let's make goals as to what's a
reasonable outcome and you always focus
on function what do you want to do that
you can't do and how do we help you get
to do that um
so again it's everything's got to be
patient centered and to be honest that
is the flaw with the system is we kind
of force everybody into a funnel rather
than allowing us to take everybody as an
individual and treat them as an
individual so the answer to your
question is very individual does that
help and and you can this is on
available online actually it's called
the Gilbertson guide if you Google that
it'll come
up okay so
here's how I see
this okay Dad and uh and I would say
that probably truthfully because I've
been doing Insurance a long
time
and in terms of
my experience you this is um it's an
issue that really is longterm you know
it's the pain is not necessarily going
to go away right away but I think what's
interesting about this legislation is it
is a classic uh cart before the horse or
should I say is is a more like uh the
chicken of the
egg I think the problem is that our
Medical Care system and someone has P
back pain they go to their primary care
physician and the primary care physician
refers them to the physical you know the
the phys the Doctor Who and that doctor
say okay let's let you know have you in
the physical therapy let's try to do
this and stuff that doctor will never
mention the word
Chiropractic
never okay they have a thing about I
will disagree with you but keep going
they well maybe you are different but
I'm just telling you that most
doctors think chiropractors are are
practice is
sketchy okay I personally believe this
all right and what they want to do yeah
they're going to send you off to the
surgeon right because they because you
got this back problem and surgery is the
right way to go right but as we know
surgery is the most expensive way to go
yep okay so what we're going to say when
we take this this project on here is
that we're going
to we can't tell doctors what to do with
because that that's the whole point of
healthcare system is that they do know
better and that we're Supply but I'm
going to refer to a certain section in
your bill here in page two Roman numeral
five and I assume it's the same again on
on the two sections so point out for
everybody for Education this is two
different statutes so you see on page
one it starts with
6bb and then the same thing all over
again on page three where it said 415
1888 so these are the two different uh
health insurance statutes we have in the
state okay one is for the individual the
other one is for the small group um I
would say this is where I saw the word
yoga yeah it was still there you we need
to take that out you didn't delete you
deleted it from the first section but
you didn't delete it from the section
you're right we need to get rid of it
let just that covers up our conversation
we had this morning yeah that was a fun
conversation but here's what I want to
focus in on okay and this no it said no
insurance how established util
utilization
controls including prior Ops or step
therapy this is really important to me
and that is if someone has a back pain
problem
we can't tell that doctor the doctor to
say don't send them to the surgeon don't
send that page to the
church only the insurance companies
might say when it comes to the prior
off have they been to a chiropractic yet
now this is a revolutionary
idea right because we've never thought
of it that is saying to have we're now
saying is because we all think hmos are
evil right curse of the world okay
because they manage us okay but reality
is the whole phrase well I'm not sure
what if this is the step the therapy I'm
thinking of I think they're different
but keep going but I think was this is
drug step therapy yeah but I'm thinking
is is that we want we take we what we
want to do is think in terms of what
steps should be taken first before you
go to that surgeon why because the
surgeon is the most most expensive thing
you can do and that's the one thing
manag care companies are great at is to
try to get us to do the cheap one
first right that's done under the prior
off so I I'm going to ask you to think
about this yeah is ADD will rethink
about how we're doing this and that is
that I know your bill is set up is is
that that the insurance company is
supposed to set up what they're
offering okay but at the end of the day
what
when we say what they're offering we
need to be say to them is they can start
off with those things that are the least
invasive and and uh and and maybe less
expensive and then move up to those
higher more expensive things okay so I'm
just want to let you know that I I
really have a problem with those those
limitations because I'm thinking that's
where the answer is so I agree with
everything you have said
totally um I don't the only thing I
don't necessarily agree with I think
doctors and chiropractors get along a
lot better than they used to but
certainly when I started out everything
you just said was true um my I'm
numbering my friends but my I don't know
we do have you but he's my fifth best
friend that there so um what I'm not
going to be your best friend your number
six I'm sorry we I'm sorry the list is
taken but actually representative post
went ahead of you but um right so
because he's Cent I mean you basically
gave me a segue to recommend my book I
mean that's basically what I talked
about in the book is that fiscally
doctors are are totally irresponsible
and prior authorization does have a lot
of value because of that
irresponsibility and you know I with my
prior off bill when I testified last
year I said very specifically that a lot
of doctors won't like what I'm about to
say but I think they're a necessary evil
because of the way we do things um you
know with that you gave me an I hope
you're not exciting me um for no good
reason but like the concept of us
working together that paragraph stinks
it really needs a lot I just want you to
say that that's where I'm we're going to
run if we're going to run on the concept
is that we know that the number one
problem is is everybody's going to that
expensive surgeon right out the top and
then with bad results then then then
they finally come back and look at these
the cheaper ones they could have worked
out right and not as as intrusive toally
might have so the problem is we now have
a conflict between what the our Health
Care system is designed to work in terms
of getting our positions and now we're
now we're giving a whole new
responsibility to insurance companies so
I'm not even sure they're too excited
about this idea okay so I would say is
we have to kind of work this is going to
take an art form to get this to a place
Y where everyone feels comfortable with
what we're trying to set up here with
the goal that is is going to be the
least e you know the the least expensive
way to get that pain cured uh so knowing
full well that the surgeon and some
people will say is they'll say I God I'm
so upset they forc me to do all these
other things instead of going to the
surgeon and I knew that I just want to
go to that surgeon right out of the
block okay that will be our number one
problem okay so having said that um I
know that we we have a lot of people who
are going to want to speak yes okay and
so what I want to urge everyone to say
is is that we get it we understand what
we're doing here right we we get and how
we want to get to so let's try to be
aware that that's where we're going to
go and let's not you know blavor too
much because I think we all really get
that each one of these different
practices do does something very helpful
and is less expensive than what is
occurring now in this country which is
the surgeon you know if you had said
that be when we started I wouldn't said
it word you would have I would you said
everything I wanted to say perfect good
job thank you very much thank you okay
so we'll start out with Roberta
blades uh pain uh pain patience and
friend number what what number were you
all
right I've just had the flu for two
weeks but I've had antibiotics I just
don't want to get anyone El I I've had
my flu shots and my co shots so I'm I'm
okay not
worried um good afternoon for the record
my name is Roberta blades and I live in
conquer New
Hampshire I
have been living with chronic pain um at
least since 2016 when I had a major um
move that was wrong and I was in
screeching pain went by ambulance to the
hospital stayed there 4 days was treated
with opioids was
discharged with fewer opioids than I
needed to manage um went home could not
walk and I had VNA services for at least
6 months to teach me how to walk again I
had to use opioids to move so I took
them in the morning when the VNA came so
I could move and build up my endurance
and strength again um
but I'm I'm not on any strong opioids
now I do take a variety of medications
for chronic pain
um the biggest change in my life was in
2017 um when one of my medical doctors
who was giving me epidurals in my spine
to help with the pain he's in the room
you might know him um Dr Nagel um he
said to me I said there's got to be
something more than
invasive injections surgeries which I
never had for this I've had for things
um there has to be more and he said to
me look up us pain
foundation.org and then he introduced me
to Cindy Steinberg who's in the room who
you'll meet who is one of their um
advocacy people um and she became a
mentor of sorts I went to her support
group in Arlington
Mass and I made the track because she
was amazing
and taught me so
much
um and now shortly after I went through
the training and now I lead support
groups for the US pain Foundation as
well and the one I run is for people
from New Hampshire but I get a lot of
people from other states as well and
it's Zoom opened my world Zoom meant
that I could run these support groups
from home and zoom would would allow
people to test give testimony here if
you allowed it like other states I just
like to mention that it is a real open
door for people like me but I um I'm in
a lot of pain because I also couldn't
take my medicines to drive and I'm very
I'm very strict with myself I'm I don't
drink because my medications don't allow
me to and I'm not a one who enjoys
feeling lost or as you know out of
control that's not me um I wanted to get
better and I have learned through so
much through US pain Foundation it's
more than just support groups but in
running these groups I'd like to share
some of the things that I've learned
um I've learned more
acronyms more cases for chronic pain
people introduce themselves and say I
have CRPS I have fibromyalgia I have
this I have that and they'll many of us
have more than one
condition
and CRPS chronic regional pain syndrome
in many cases some of these patients had
a bad ankle that they broke had surgery
for it the surgeon somehow nicked a
nerve or whatever and it sets off pain
that radiates and goes to other parts of
their body now I that's not a medical
definition it's just mine but in other
words some of these conditions
um are also provoked by surgery and as
you said surgery is the most expensive
uh perhaps
um the other thing about my support
groups
um suicides when I have heard so many
people who were so desperate when
opioids were taken away from them
because they were man managing their
pain they were not addicted in fact I
get data from New Hampshire every month
it says what's causing the
deaths what were the substances illegal
fenel from China from other countries is
number one mixtures of drugs or somebody
used somebody else's drugs but very
rarely will you see a pain patient there
because pain patients use it to make the
pain go away and to offer that us pain
Foundation has a great website they have
a lot of people who volunteer like
myself do not get paid and they know a
lot there are pain management um
Comprehensive Pain Services management
plan we talked about in this bill um
they don't have an identical thing but
there are examples and there are people
who could advise so that it's not like
it's a desert and that you have to start
from scratch when you look at this
bill um Educational Services right there
um phological pharmacological and
non-pharmacological I want to point out
something I'm just sharing some personal
stories I hope you don't mind pain
patches lioc cane pain patches they were
5% and I got them on prescription it was
so wonderful and all of a sudden they
said we're going to make it 4% is over
the counter now and 5% is only good for
these two conditions and neither one I
have a lot of conditions but neither one
for that so I've been using 4% and it
makes a difference I would love to get
5% again and I would love to um have it
covered by medical insurance I pay $2 a
day out of pocket just for that and I do
it um and it's only 4% so I'm just
saying these ways of changing things um
you talk about prior oth and step
therapy I have a doctor who says he
won't do prior oth if he's if the
insurance company tells it him about it
he's not doing it for that customer who
might be me that patient um doctors have
put through so many things and it's one
more thing that they have to you know go
through
um mental health mindfulness meditation
these are all offered by us pain
foundation and
um manual treatments massage therapy I
mean you would probably all like massage
therapy but I don't
think um it will be taken advantage of
we're we're limiting things to what 12
episodes or 12
um times that you can have this and I
think it would help I get muscle spasms
and sometimes you know I've eaten a
dozen bananas to try and magnesium and
this and that but wouldn't I love to
have massage therapy um and have a real
therapist one of my problems before I uh
thought oh I can have acupuncture but
the the people who were covered by my
insurance were over an hour away and in
my condition driving an hour is a lot um
so all these
things one more um I was given invasive
treatment that was more expensive and I
kept asking my doctor can I please have
aquatic therapy I have heard so many
good things about pool
PT and I couldn't get it and I couldn't
get it and then finally I said this
other therapy is not helping me and it's
expensive finally got pooled
PT what happens when you go in a
pool gravity's gone it's there but not
as strong and the pull on your body you
are moving lightly and the pain subsides
and you can do exercises again coming
out is hard because then all the gravity
pulls you down but it's a definite
remedy for people you can build up your
muscles and get a little bit further in
your own health um I'm currently doing
Tai Chi online there are so many spinal
cord injury um foundations that offer
exercises online for upper body that are
free so there are things that are in
this bill that are also free and
resources out there so I just wanted to
share that because um I don't want you
to be overwhelmed by the thought of the
costs because there are people who do do
it for free and could help um there are
other states who have similar bills and
it they're ongoing now um so
I'm happy to answer any questions and
thank you for letting me speak um I just
want to say having insurance coverage
for more treatments of pain is critical
for people with pain in New Hampshire
please
help thank you very much for your tesy
thank
you uh chair we call an Amy Odell Wilson
representing the acupuncture Association
bill
was afternoon afternoon good afternoon
thank you for this opportunity to speak
for the record my name is Amy Odell
Wilson I'm a licensed acupuncturist
and I'm also the vice president of
nahama which is the New Hampshire
acupuncture and Asian medicine
Association um I'm on two hats here one
is the vice president to let you know
that we stand in support and Nama of
this bill and also um as a self
representative as a licensed
acupuncturist because education in the
state is necessary there are still um
many people who don't know the benefits
of acupun puncture don't realize the
scope of the practice what is necessary
in the practice so what I've handed you
is the position letter um from Nama and
what I'm going to actually speak on are
some very specific cases from my
practice over the Last 5 Years um I came
to acupuncture late in my life and it's
been an incredible um Incredible Journey
um listening to Dr Nagel's speak there
was a couple of things that I didn't
think I was going to speak on but I want
to point out to you um first of all on
the back of the packet that I sent out
or is circulating around there's a
resource there's a table um
representative Sullivan some of the
questions that you
had um one of the questions was um in
comparing different modalities the r
resource there there's a
um citation to a bigger article if you
were to take that home put it into the
web you'd find the article with the
tables I tried to print them but the
font was so ridiculously tiny there was
no way you would be able to see it but
at home you would be able to and they're
comparing different non-invasive
modalities and what is effective and
also in that packet
is a chart that
shows the usage of
opioids across many different countries
and you'll happen to notice that South
Korea and Japan as the the least amount
and those are two areas where
traditional Asian medicine is the
highest and acupuncture is used in also
as Dr Nagel pointed out they use things
like Chiang and taii and massage and
nutrition and nbal
Medicine you also asked about the cost
of things um and thinking about that and
we not that I have a particular study to
hand to you but as I go through
different patients I can tell you the
cost of those things and um just to
think to start out to think about a
patient's in pain they go to their
PCP in that treatment maybe it lasted 15
minutes maybe they're there for 30
minutes they walk out and they're still
in pain and when they get the bill
several hundred to see that PCP and
they're still in pain then they go to a
pharmacy or they get referred to another
practitioner they're still in pain and
yet they've had multiple office visits
$700 and nothing's happened
yet so in Converse to that I see people
they come in an acute pain or chronic
pain um and within one visit I've
knocked their pain
down and my visits aren't several
hundred and although it is true that
acupuncture requires multiple visits in
order to have long
standing that that's different from
Patient to Patient some patients come in
once or twice the Pain's diminished
they're back to work
$160 pretty low cost other patients come
in in a short sequence maybe twice a
week um for a short period of time their
Pain's knocked down they're back to
work and it's still a lower cost than
one or two visits with
PCP so here's just a couple of examples
so that you have some talking points
when you're talking more knowledgeably
about acupuncture in the
future some of the patients that I'm
currently seeing one to 38-year-old male
he's a commercial pilot he was um
serving in the armed
forces in December he came up with
radiating pain down his
arm there was no possibility of taking
certain prescriptions or his he would be
grounded he had um gone to his PCP he
was referred to PT PT was full wouldn't
be able to get in for several months he
went to massage therapist because of his
muscle muscle structure um his massage
therapist wasn't able to work with him
and referred him to me and within one
visit his pain was knocked down and some
of the feeling that he had lost in his
hand had started to return within seven
visits between December and March all of
the radi getting pain and his arm was
gone his arm was his hand was restored
to full function and it was 3 months
after his initial visit with the PCP
that he finally was able to get in for
his scheduled MRI which they found disk
damage in his spine and but in seven
visits we were able to restore the
function of his arm and the cost of that
was
$680 I have a 73-year-old who's had
cancer three different times massive
cancer in her neck um when she came to
me her skin was about the color of the
papers in front of you she could barely
turn her neck she had no saliva from the
massive radiation in her
neck um her oncologist referred her to M
um to an
acupuncturist
and the first acupuncturist actually
said I don't know how to help you and
then she got my name came to me and
we've been working and I said you know
this is new for me but we're going to go
for it I started to look at some
evidence-based things that other people
had done and we started to work within
one session her saliva started to come
back not fully but she had moisture in
her
mouth and over the course of the time
I've been working with her the radiating
pain has diminished she's gotten the
full color of her skin is back range of
motion is back
and she's one of the reasons she
couldn't take some of the opioid
medications is because they dry you out
so even though they're good for pain
that makes the saliva worse um I've been
seeing her over the the first 12 visits
um
was reducing that pain and getting her
back to normal and um she has now been
with me for 3 years on her own accord
and all of these are out of pocket she
did have another radiation kind of reset
she had came back to visit with me again
and over the course of the three years
that she's been with me she's had just
under $55,000 in a of pocket costs but
it's the only therapy that's been able
to restore her
function um a 28-year-old contractor who
works on
roofs and he came to me with severe um
upper back pain and although insurance
does cover acute and lower back pain
they don't cover it unless you've had it
for about 12
weeks they don't cover upper back pain
it's only for lower back
pain and he came and said I can't go on
any kind of medications because I need
to work and be on the roof and be safe
I'm also afraid of addiction I don't
want to use any cannabis for the same
reason within one visit I had his pain
knocked down
and managed to we talked about his
stress we talked about his
sleep and in just three visits he was
back to work total cost of
$240 a 26-year-old who had his I'm sorry
to interrupt yeah um just in the
consideration of time we have a lot of
people coming behind you if you could
just uh give us your final thoughts
thank you I'll just um summarize
that acupuncture needs part of the bill
is talking about the repetition of
things and having it qualified and one
is we need more than one visit it needs
to be covered 12 visits might be enough
it might not be enough the limiting
factors of having a licensed acupuncture
or licensed practitioner is
necessary um and um having a multimodal
approach so that patients are able to
choose so if one thing isn't working
they can come and try something else and
I'll take any
questions all right I'm temporary chair
for a few minutes here um any questions
from the
committee okay I think we have a lot of
thank you questions during the
subcommittee all right uh next
up uh we'll call John Jour am I saying
that correctly John
dour and you're from the New Hampshire
Psychological Association
and you support the
Bill thank you Mr chairman members of
the committee for the record my name is
John dejoy I'm here representing the New
Hampshire Psychological Association and
we are in fact pleased to support this
legislation uh the New Hampshire
Psychological Association is the
membership Organization for licensed
psychologists in the state of New
Hampshire I'm I am not an expert on this
but Dr Walter unfortunately was unable
to make it and asked me to submit
testimony which I'm going to do I'm
going to excerpt one of two pieces of
her testimony and then I'll end my my
comments at that
point uh Dr Walder points out the
importance of this bill for pain
management she also points out the
importance of the multidisciplinary
approach which is taken in this
legislation in fact those of you from
last session probably remember uh the
primary care Behavioral Health bill this
actually utilizes pieces of primary care
Behavioral Health to have Physicians and
therapists working together and we think
that's a a terrific approach to this she
mentions three other types of treatment
which I'll read them but I'm not going
to explain them pain catastrophizing
mental defeat and psychosocial factors
that apparently are important
considerations in the treatment of
trauma and she's looking at pain
management as
trauma um she also offers to provide the
psychological the American Psychological
association's clinical practice guide
for treating chronic pain conditions she
gives her email in here if anyone would
like a copy of that you can email her
and she'll send you a digital
copy um and with that I will conclude my
remarks all right great uh questions
from the committee for the
guest all right seeing none thank you
very much for your
testimony and next we have Cindy
Steinberg she's doing some pain
management therapy right now it looks
like um and you support the bill you
represent the US pain found foundation
and you request four minutes to
speak thank you very much um I
appreciate you
uh listening to my uh uh com uh comments
so I am from the US pain Foundation you
may have heard that we are a national
patient organization we have about
35,000 members around the country people
living with chronic pain um from all
different conditions as you've heard a
myriad of conditions P pull the
microphone right up to your there sure
and there's a YouTube audience so smile
for the camera there okay thank you
so uh as you've heard people have pain
from a a myriad of conditions and
serious injuries in fact the CDC has
said in New Hampshire alone there are
225,000 people living with chronic pain
and
79,000 of those have high impact chronic
pain that means pain that interferes
with your ability to function on a daily
basis these people are devastated by
their pain they can't work they can't
take care of their family they can't
take care of their children um we're
talking Relentless 24/7 pain and where
many of you were talking about um the
cost of some of these treatments think
about the ability to possibly go back to
work to not be on disability pain is the
number one cause of disability in this
country um and so it is a huge burden
and huge problem now many people here
have talked about uh different approach
for treating pain and I wanted to tell
you about a task force that I sat on
where this idea of multimodal pain
treatment comes from and it's kind of uh
this bill which we strongly support
really backs that report and that is as
the Director of policy and advocacy for
us pain Foundation I'm often going to
Capitol Hill and when the opard crisis
hit a lot of Congress people said to us
well what's the problem why don't we
just get rid of
opioids and basically what we said was
what else are people going to do because
there hasn't been a new medication for
pain to come to the market in more than
a decade and so you've got
over-the-counter and then you've got
opioids and in between doctors often use
things off label but there's a Dar of
medications for for severe pain and so
when when this C happen Congress said to
us well in this opioid Bill and there
was a big Federal opioid Bill kill
carara we want to appoint an expert of
pain management specialist to tell us
what is the best way to manage pain now
in this
country and basically I was appointed to
that was the only patient everyone else
were pain doctors it was headed up by a
pain physician from Stanford
University and our conclusion was what
you've been hearing in 2019 because it
has become the standard of pain
treatment now and that is we looked at
all the possible treatments that fall
into five categories
medication complimentary treatments
Interventional procedures restorative
treatments like PT and OT and behavioral
treatments like the psychologist who
just spoke here and the conclusion was
you need to develop a treatment plan for
each person with pain because there's so
many different reasons people have pain
and so many different types of pain and
draw the treatments from any of these
and in each of those categories we
listed all the different treatments
possible and that in fact really has
become the standard of care which is
even when it comes to medication you
still
it's not a Panacea it doesn't take away
the pain there is no cure for chronic
pain it is now known to be a disease of
the nervous system and
brain and the best way to manage it is
combining these treatments as Dr Nagel
has said and finding the rest the best
combination and the way that works and I
heard this representative ask well what
what happens with that how how do you
solve pain if each treatment takes down
your pain another 10 or 15 % and you
combine those the difference between
having pain at a super high level and
50% of that pain might mean the
difference between being able to work or
not being on disability or not and so
that really is the best way to manage
pain yes the psychologist who spoke the
acupuncture who spoke Dr Nel who
spoke those help people but not everyone
some people are helped by acupuncture I
happen to live with pain the way I
manage it is I take a medication called
emat tripoline I limit the amount of
time I'm upright my back was crushed and
a serious injury you saw me laying down
I alternate all day and I do a water
water-based exercise program and with
those things together I've managed learn
to manage my life and that's what we
mean by self-management we don't mean oh
somebody has severe a severe migraine
just manage it yourself we
combine these different treatments learn
your own body and figure out how you can
bring down the level of pain such that
you can function and that's what we do
at us pain Foundation we expose people
in the support groups like you've heard
Bobby she's a terrific support group
leader and we teach them how to combine
these treatments to bring their pain
down to a reasonable level and so that's
why when the opioid crisis hit and all
these people were being forc tapered off
of opioids there were 5 to8 million
people using opioids the ni said in 2014
before the the CDC guidelines came in
place that that has been reduced over
60% and so many of those people were
forced off and we heard from Desperate
patients who were doing well on them but
can no longer get them and doctors won't
prescribe and we're not going back there
really we need new Solutions and so
right now while we're waiting for some
new medications in the pipeline and
we're very optimistic that new medic
non-addictive medications are in the
pipeline and coming because I think for
pretty severe pain you need some sort of
medication in combination with other
things but really the best way is to
manage pain by combining different
things that work for you and that you
know your physician should help you with
those different things I found somebody
that helped me and I combine those
different things to manage my pain same
thing with Bobby she couldn't be here
unless she had learned behavioral
techniques and other techniques to help
manage her pain in addition to
medication that she uses and so that's
how we teach people to be functional and
so this bill which we strongly
support would enable people to get
access to therapies that they can't get
access to now because they can't afford
them and why not try these non-invasive
nonrisky
procedures as we've talked about surgery
is often optional an option for people
and I've seen many surgeries go right
and I've seen many surgeries go wrong
I've been leading a support group for 24
years I've seen patient many patients
who've had multiple back surgeries and
they're still in pain and then a lot of
people are are really reluctant to go to
pain clinics because pain clinics these
days only do Interventional procedures
they've stopped prescribing they don't
offer these other options because they
don't have the practitioners and they
don't have the insurance coverage and so
most people when they go to pain clinics
get
injections like anything else they help
a small percentage maybe 10 or 15% of
the people and the other people they
don't help and what we see is insurance
companies readily agreeing to pay for
nerve blocks epidural injections all
kind trigger point injections because
that's covered and doctors get a fair
amount of money for for doing those so
they're willing to do those but yet
these other things aren't covered so our
feeling is this is a reasonable approach
we're saying 12 visits a year and of of
these things and why not try these less
invasive less costly less rkly
procedures like acupuncture like
behavioral treatment in combination you
know with some other things so in the
long run we think it's less costly I
have to tell you in 24 years of seeing
more than 600 people that have come to
this little support group that I lead
everyone has been on Years Journey to
Find help with chronic pain I mean it
took me five years I had so many tests
and different procedures and nerve
blocks and injections and ultimately
what helped me was a doctor who said you
know let's try this water-based therapy
let's try this medication and let's
let's try limiting the amount of time
you're upright and learning what your
body needs right people with chronic
migraines can't handle a lot of lights
or certain Medic or certain foods that
trigger them in combination with
migraine medications and avoiding those
things they learn to manage their pain
so this is not at all what I was going
to talk about but I figured an answer to
a lot of your questions that have been
risen about how's the best way to manage
pain why you know this is this going to
be more costly I've tried to answer some
some of those things with with this
answer
and um I think Dr Nagel is a really
terrific pain physician he's told you
the truth he does Interventional but he
has you know used these treatments and
they've they've helped people and you
know I think he's done a really
thoughtful job with this bill and so you
know we strongly support his efforts
with this bill so I'm happy to take any
questions that you have
see thank you very
much
okay we've done the pro now we'll do in
between Michelle
heon the H depart Department which takes
no position on the
bill thank you everyone for the record
my name is Michelle heat I'm director of
life and health with the New Hampshire
insurance department and I have here Dr
Jason AIS who is our director of Health
economics um as representative hunt said
we don't take a position on this bill
there's just a couple things we wanted
to point out um with respect to our
fiscal note so this statute um aims to
just so you know we have not seen the
fiscal note Oh I thought it was on it's
on on on the bill that got posted I
think on what we have right now is all
the
zeros oh well when I looked it up they
may have just gotten posted you went
online yeah is it online I believe so
because I just pulled it up okay great
but I can walk you through it so um give
us the highlights it aims to amend two
different statutes 4156 by adding a new
um section in
41518 so that's individual and group to
the extent this creates new mandates for
the individual and small group Market um
those are benefits in addition to um ehb
in some respects some of the stuff
mentioned in this bill is already
covered by insurance but I think there's
some areas that are not and are not part
of our Benchmark plan so to the extent
it expands what we're already required
to offer um it could be subject from to
Def frail by the state and that's a cost
that the state would have to take on
it's indeterminable because we have no
idea of estimating what that would be um
we can do a mandate analysis but um that
would would require you guys to direct
us to do it and those typically cost a
department between 20 and $40,000 to
conduct a mandate analysis so we'
encourage you to do that sparingly um
another aspect of this bill is that
there's a requirement that they file
that um carers make certain filings with
us and that we would approve um some of
these filings as um clinical guidelines
we do not have expertise um on staff to
review any kind of um medical necessity
type things or to weigh in on the
medical appropriateness of any kind of
clinical guidelines so that would be
something that would be difficult for us
to approve and we would need probably
$250,000 in addition to our budget to
Outsource this work to the appropriate
um vendor have a medical director on
staff right yeah we wouldn't be able to
hire one but we can Outsource some of
this work I don't think it's a full-time
job but um we could get a vendor to do
it um but it's going to cost money that
is currently um not accounted for in our
current budget so there is an added
expense there so I think those are some
of the highlights and Jason do you want
to add anything no unless you have
questions great thank
you
okay okay now we have the dark throwers
all right uh Andrew
osmer repr representing Harvard
I was going to say you were my favorite
Senator but I see I have another senator
in the
room I get two now well um Dr Nagel has
a top 10 of friends so long as
uh Senator Kev and I make your top five
Senators we're good with that good
afternoon uh my name is Ander Hosmer um
today I sit before you representing
Harvard Pilgrim
Healthcare 32 which is New Hampshire's
largest nonprofit insurer so I will try
to keep my remarks brief knowing this is
going to subcommittee and there's still
an awful lot of work to do but I will
say to all of you uh Mr chair our
members Harvard Pilgrim strongly
supports Pain Management
Services um that are alternatives to
opioids however uh we believe this bill
is unnecessary because insurers already
cover a wide range of pain management
treatment options including most of the
services listed in this
bill we support a wide range of
evidence-based treatments for pain
management as alternatives to opioids
Harvard Pilgrim uh in its robust array
of programs covers things like physical
therapy and occupational therapy
chiropractic care and acupuncture
behavioral health care including
counseling and cognitive behavioral
therapy while we do not cover meditation
though through external providers
mindfulness meditation resources are
available on our website and accessible
to the general public it's not just for
our members the resources include essays
about uses of mindfulness for managing
chronic pain and recordings of guided
medic uh meditations excuse
me though sometimes portrayed as
hardened of heart certainly listening to
people testify today it's easy to feel a
great deal of empathy for folks who are
dealing with chronic pain and I will say
to you that um as part of our mission is
um at Harvard
Pilgrim is that patients must receive
the highest quality health care and
improving outcomes all the time um I
also let you know we also provide
coverage from many FDA approved
prescription non-opioid drug products
that are effective pain management
Alternatives and have a lesser potential
for misuse than opioid drug products
including uh topical analgesics and
costero steroids excuse me Harvard
Pilgrim already has an easily accessible
member facing website specifically
addressing pain management that links
members directly to their specific
benefits page so they can understand the
coverage that they
have also significant in this is
insurers design plans that meet the
needs of their membership while every
plan may not cover each Pain Management
Service there are a variety of plan
types with varying benefit designs
allowing members to choose a plan that
best meets their needs this allows
insurers to meet the needs of their
membership while also keeping costs as
affordable as
possible while we appreciate
Representatives Nagel representative
Nagel's goal of increasing access in a
cost- effective manner there will be an
increased cost when any new benefit is
required or mandated even if there is a
low cost with this mandate one thing
that we take into consideration is the
cost of other mandate the state passes
this session and add that cost to the
mandates passed in previous years when
considered in totality it all adds up to
a significant cost to employers and
consumers in this state I think finally
as well we need to consider the ability
of some of these provider types to
submit claims for their services for
example this mandate would require us to
cover
massage while massage therapists are
licensed in New Hampshire and certainly
do provide benefits to those with pain
management in their pain management are
they really in a position to submit
claims for reimbursement through our
operating system if not it'll be
challenging for Harvard Pilgrim to build
an adequate Network that satisfies some
of these sole providers or smaller
practices um with that I will conclude
my testimony on behalf of Harvard
Pilgrim healthare I'm happy to take any
questions that you may
have uh we just want your
testimony I will provide it at some
point here
it's in turn absolutely any questions
thank you very much thank you chair will
call on Sabrina D from
Anthem thank you chairman hunt members
of the committee my name is Sabrina
Dunlap I'm director of government
relations for
Anthem um and I just wanted to say we've
been working on this bill or a version
of this bill for many years I was
talking to rep Nel about when did this
first appear I think it was 21 or 22 um
and I I think the bill has come a long
way and certainly we've been part of
work groups and had very good
discussions about these issues um I
think there's still problems with it
I'll try to be brief I Echo much of what
um Andrew already said but first off
again we already cover many of the
services listed here Chiropractic
acupuncture act CBT and and others as
well um and you know we want members to
have access to these sort of alternative
treatments I think there's only so much
you can do as an insurance company and
at some point it comes down to Providers
and what are they pushing um there's a
bunch of practical issues and one I
would mention is network problems I know
acupuncture is covered we do have
challenges trying to get acupuncturist
in network um we can't force them into
our Network so that's just a practical
problem I suspect would play out with
others you know like massage therapists
um again some of these services are not
exactly Medical in nature like
mindfulness um I know yoga is probably
going to be taken out but how do you
define these things um there's licensing
issues there's the network problem um
how do you Bill and code for these
Services many of the services are
self-directed by the member so I'm not
sure how you account for that um there's
some issues with the bill being too Brad
I know some of those things have already
been discussed um I would just flag the
effective date I think is July 1st 2025
which would be a challenge and and um
and I'd also add this will only apply in
the fully insured Market which I know we
talk about a lot but you know it's more
pressure on a small segment of the
overall Insurance market and I think
it's worth noting when people say like
these things aren't covered it really
depends on the type of plan somebody has
um it varies widely by plan and
certainly if somebody had a self-insured
plan this bill would not change
potentially would not change anything
for them because it would not apply um
so you know happy to continue the
conversations and um try to be helpful
in any way we can on this bill but I
don't think insurance coverage is the
problem and I don't think it's the
solution um I think again this is
probably more of like a provider
education and sort of culture around how
we treat pain so thank you for letting
me speak and I'm happy to take any
questions right thank you thank you one
more card left Paula
thank you Mr chairman and good afternoon
members of the House Commerce Committee
for the record my name is Paula Rogers
and I'm here on behalf of ahip America's
health insurance plans which is trade
Association of Health insurers and
you've heard from a couple of members
Anthem and
Harvard um I was interested in
representative
Hunt's comment about perhaps some way
to enclose what's going on here in a
sort of cogent way that would deliver
some results and so before the hearing
because I've been involved years back on
the very same issue with Dr Nagel I
spoke with him and um I said you know I
know there was a bill I looked at the
legislative history from I think was two
years ago it went to interim study and
then now recommended for further
legislation and the bill has made
significant progress it was rather
expansive and difficult to see how you
could fit the framework of that b fill
into a regulatory setting and I'm having
sort of a continuing problem problem
wondering what is going on that we can't
do something so I I'm hoping I can leave
copies maybe later this week but I
Googled about and I found a journal of
American Medical Association
article very recently published I think
it was October of this year but released
for publication earlier in 24 and it has
a survey of states that have been doing
just what this committee is trying to do
and there are only seven of them that
they picked up and none of them has
really reached a a place where they feel
they've listened to everybody and
they've come up with something that will
make a difference or they're not
confident enough that they have so when
I was listening to Dr Nagel it suddenly
occurred to me and then it was prompted
by chairman Hunt's comment
some of you were probably in a
legislative setting when Integrated
Primary Care was discussed that is
weaving Behavioral Health Care into the
primary care
setting I heard statistics today and
I've been Googling about it found the
number of people that are are suffering
with chronic pain looking for treatments
and so if there are that many people why
isn't there some
interprofessional discussion going on
amongst providers including Dr n
including primary care
physicians if a patient comes to you
which is where most people go because
they start with their primary care
doctor and they have chronic pain yes
you can see them but you need to already
have in your mind as a professional with
an integrated view of the world if this
person has pain do I begin to tell him
or her what the alternatives are and do
I deal with in an integrated beh
behavioral situation there's a care
manager
there's the specialist there's the
primary care provider that needs to
Encompass this challenge because I was
shocked when I saw the number of people
that are chronically in discomfort so
when I spoke with Dr Nagel I indicated
that an ahip would be happy to continue
in a conversation and I don't think
people should sort of give up and throw
up their hands there may be something
that can be done that would sort of
begin to formulate something to address
the people that came here and testified
who are struggling so I'd be happy to
answer any questions but I I don't have
many answers
so so I I was thinking
um that the the best way if we were to
try to direct patients to go think about
would be through co-pays and
deductibles and and they show you know
and with using those as a way for a
patient to help them see that uh doing
something alternate you know would be a
better way to do that um rather than
going directly to the
surgeon exactly and so in a primary care
setting with the sort of umbrella of
understanding that this person presents
with a discomfort and chronic pain pain
what are my Alternatives out of primary
care and have I sort of internalized
that and can I Aid well we can't expect
so much of the primary being being know
knowledgeable about co-pays and
deductibles okay no but that that that
they refer to the in terms the uh the
insurance company um would then uh have
some or maybe have something with the
primary career's office or have
something that some notication where
they would get a list of how of how we
want to direct them to think about doing
these Alternatives before going to that
surgeon I think that's the sort of
discussion that we should engage in
because we can be creative and creative
using then those and and our carrots is
the is the or or in this case it could
be the hammer but that in terms of the
deductibles and coopas is to get them to
think you know one versus the other
initially that's what I'm thinking thank
you thank you very much whoops yes
represent Gibbs thank you Mr chairman
um if I understood correctly um you were
talking about a large part of the
problem being lack of coordination among
providers did I understand that
correctly I think there needs to be more
inter professional discussion about pain
because I I was shocked when I heard the
statistics so primary care physicians
must encounter it
frequently um followup for the question
may inquire thank you uh do you have any
suggestions as to how that coordination
could be done well I think that's a
question that should go back to the
professionals because if it's a
challenge for caregiving then just like
Behavioral Health which what four five
six years ago the federal government
developed a healthc care model for an
integrated practice for behavioral
health problems which have a similar
kind of in fact there there's Behavioral
Health counseling that's helpful for
pain management but it's a it's sort of
a more nebulous thing you're treating
and there are an array of opportunities
to have a positive effect well then
inter professionally that ought to be
more that the primary care practice
ought to be more comfortable with
understanding the array of things and of
course it comes up then the insurance
coverage sometimes is a difficult thing
and that's a coordination issue with a
office manager so I don't I don't have
the answers I just know something's
missing thank
you so thank you Paul okay thank you so
represent we do have one more Bill we
got to get through here but this will be
really quick okay um so the only reason
I'm here is to solve that problem you
have to speak to the oh yeah yeah sorry
is to solve that problem there and
there's a number of moving pieces that
are ongoing right now to look at how do
we coordinate all of our resources
within the state so that we work
together as a team rather than as silos
because Silo isation is a huge problem
in the state so we are looking at that
in about four or five different ways so
don't wor we're working on it we we'll
solve it okay we are great thank
you okay having no more cards I will
close the public
hearing and we have one more Bill left
the sponsors left the house so have the
insurance department who she she told me
that you guys requested her to put this
bill in yeah okay
so what I'll do is I will read her
testimony in so it's officially in on
YouTube and then and then uh and then
you guys can make your
presentation um so so uh uh this bill
the request of the insurance department
was to strengthen New Hampshire's
program for collecting and de
identifying health insurance claims data
from all payers New Hampshire was one of
the first states to establish on an all
payers claim database known in other
states as
apcd but known in New Hampshire as chis
comprehensive healthare information
system the chis has been essentially to
essential to the state's efforts to make
healthc care costs and spending more
transparent and to support
evidence-based policy making under
Employee Retirement income Security Act
Arisa states are limited authority to
collect data from employer plans that
are self-funded in order to address this
limitation the Hampshire legislature
created an opt-in program an RSA 420 G11
Roman numi whereby self-funded employers
can opt into providing their
deidentified clim Nam data into the uh
comprehensive Healthcare information
system to strengthen the opt-in program
this bill provides that any self-funded
employer that opts out of the uh system
will have to access their own claim data
self-funded employers often use this
data to improve their employee health
benefit plans but sometimes run into
problems that the Claims Administrator
treats the claims data as proprietary
and not available to that self-funded
employer under this bill by opting into
the uh tins Pro Chris progam a
self-funded employer will no longer have
this
problem represent excuse me your title
I'm sorry I trying to remember what your
title was director of life and health
director of Life yeah so well hello
everyone again for the record my name is
Michelle Heaton I'm the director of Life
and Health at the New Hampshire
insurance department and I have here
with with me Dr jayon Asis who is our
director of Health economics um this is
a bill that we have asked representative
spear to bring on our behalf and what
we're trying to do with it is to
strengthen the amount of data we're
getting in our chiz system are all cleed
all all paired claims database
um under Arisa and federal law um we are
not allowed to require self-funded plans
to submit their data they have to opt in
and that's been the law for some time
now um after some federal cases came out
so what we're trying to do with this
amendment is to give an incentive to
those self-funded plans to um opt in and
give us their data and the incentive is
that if you do opt into the system and
agree to submit your data then we will
give you um your essential cut of the
data so that you can look at your own
claims Administration so we think this
um will'll be able to absorb any
additional
um administrative functions already in
our current budget so we don't think
there's going to be any kind of fiscal
impact for it so and Dr Jason AES is the
one who really works closely with the
chis and can answer any of your
questions so you're the new Tyler
Brandon then yeah yeah as of three years
ago I just wanted to point out um right
now I think there's a misconception that
the the chis only contains the fully
insured data about 28% right now of the
chis are self-insured members of the
state and so it's a really high utility
health information data set and by
strengthening it this way and having
greater representation of this
self-insured Market um it only gets
better and more utility for the for this
committee and the citizens of the
state just one more thing I want to add
is that on this bill the effective date
is 60 days after passage um and speaking
with industry they would prefer for that
to be January 1 we have no objection to
that so if you want to make an amendment
that's fine with
us so I I think this is a good way of
looking at the bill even though I think
I know that behind the bill there was a
different issue that was what this is
about but I would say that one of the uh
things that I know in the past when it
came to um this data being released um
and especially when we talk about a
single employer and getting employer
information so in this case you're
saying the employer's not going to get
it you're only you're going to get it or
is the employer still going to get it no
we would give um the employer at the end
of their plan year we would give them
their data back so we would be able to
facilitate that for that which is what
they were looking for um and I would
just say you know I want to on tape that
the uh one of the underlying issues why
that was always considered um uncouth
because um some employers could then
figure out which employee was costing
them all that money by looking at that
data so uh that was always a uh a sore
point that that we that why they were
not being given the data is that it's
that they don't want uh the employer to
you know say well
chief that I can't believe that employee
cost us that much money
but most employers with Risa have a stop
Gap
coverage and so you know they wouldn't
know it until the the Gap coverage got
kicked in but it is it is a problem of
being a self-funded plan and having that
claims
data okay any questions yes representa
sharesa thanks for taking a question uh
so I I have a quick uh I just want to
understand this by self-funded employer
health benefit plan means people who buy
their own insurance from Marketplace or
is it something different no these are
employers that um keep the risk with
them so they agree to cover all health
care costs for their employees so they
don't purchase um Large Group Insurance
products which is what we regulate they
keep that risk for themselves and it's
up to them to design and Implement those
plans so the history is this is actually
goes back to Gerald Ford when he was
president he signed the legislation uh
it's a federal plan and it was available
to obviously to initially people would
think it was only the employers who who
had 200 or 300 employees um I've heard
that it can get as low as 50 employees
it can get fairly down there but the
reason being is is that the employer is
now taking on the risks of of having too
many sick people in their plan and
that's why they all you know that that
uh what really open the gate floodgates
is the stop Gap coverage that they would
also uh purchase but for all tents and
purposes this is something for a large
employer who chooses not to have a fully
insured plan uh you still use uh Signa
and Anthem as your as you know in terms
of the what the card that your employe
will get uh but in the end of the day um
they are exempt from all our state Reg
regulations because they're really a
license or if license we call it Loosely
but their incorporation status is of
that that plan is through is federal
okay so let me understand if I correctly
so these this plan is basically the
employer emplo they don't go to
insurance companies they use an
insurance company to be their their
billing and paperwork and processing and
and and then paying out the bills
they still hire a separate you know
insurance company but it's not it's not
regulated it's not the status is not
under U uh let's say the the uh
Affordable Care Act which is State based
or the marketplace which is for
individuals yeah okay in this case um
this it's it's the it's it's just a
whole another separate entity of of
Regulation uh you would you would say
that the federal government does not do
a lot of regulating on on these rip
plans and and we do hear complaints
every once in a while but the most
classic story you'll get is someone says
well gee I thought New Hampshire passed
that mandate and find out that well
that's just because we passed it doesn't
mean it it happened in with that
employer um because that large employer
and especially I mean really where the
legislation really came out it was
employers who were in multiple States
yeah and so they didn't want to have a
different plan for every state they want
to have one plan for the whole
company and and that's where the really
the risk was supposed to be out of I
think was really what was why it was
created so was for large employers who
were in multi-states so I'll try to get
some more information I'll read about it
but typically when employer takes a plan
from a insurance company it submits all
all his employees information to the
insurance company that I have 10
employees and this is the information of
10 employees to the insurance company
this is different than
that so you're you're say do you get
your information of those 10 employees
no usually when an employer purchases a
insurance plan right then the insurance
company asks them the information about
as suppose they 10 employees they're ask
information about those 10 employees you
know all the you say ask information
let's make sure we understand what
you're talking about are you talking
about medical underwriting no they ask
about no everybody is insured all the
correct all the employ because it's
employer plan yes but the insurance
company still gets the information name
of the employee soci security number
whatever all those information oh yes
that's true so they they get so this are
we talking the same thing or this is a
different kind of plan we're talking
about so again in terms of the what
we're talking about in terms of you if
you're asking me let's say what plan you
have so how many employees do you have
yes there 10 employees you have 10
employees so you're going to be in the
small group Market yeah you're not going
to go to RIS plan r a plan the RIS a
plan you're going to you're going to get
the plan U not from a benefits manager
you know it's it's a you know it's a
different you're shopping in a different
location so maybe like I'll get more
information on this but what is the
objective let me ask you the question
last question what's the objective of
this bill actually why do you want to
get the claims
data uh what's the objective of this
bill well there was a federal law I
think in
2017 um that precluded self large
self-funded plans from having this MIT
into the claims data and as a
consequence there's a lower amount of
representativeness in the claims data
from those plans which in New Hampshire
I think is about
54% of the commercial Market is
self-funded we like 50 we do a good job
in New Hampshire getting um some of the
self-funded data in there I I think
largely because of the state employes
plan and the corrections and maybe
University system of New Hampshire but
we still need to strengthen the
representativeness of that large segment
of the market and that's why I think
this is this is
important however having said that in
terms of the part where I was asking
talking about how does the employer at
the end of the day get the same data
okay because uh if you're in the regular
small group Market no the employer
doesn't get the data okay the state
compiles it as as a as a mass database
and really uses it to help you uh chop
around and see what hospitals what
doctors
you know are you know are you're using
the best um you know uh you know costs
for your employees the the larger
employer who's in the Arisa they want to
be able to shop their plan and they want
to use different RIS you know benefit
you know managers get different plans
and the best way to shop it is to be
able to take your medical history of
your employees and take it to multiple
plans so that's why that's the that's
the second side of this legislation yeah
they lack their claim insights on their
claims experience so it would be you
know as a fiduciary which a lot of
self-insured large employers are that
knowledge is probably high value for
them and they don't always get it from
the contractor the the insurer that they
that they contract with is a TPA right
as a note to understand that Enigma a
little better in the claims data we
classify those those insurers that that
act as tpas as as either ASO or ASW
which means administrative Services only
or administrative services with some
other kind of rudimentary functions so
they just administer the benefits
whereas the employer takes on the
financial risk of the underlying health
conditions of their
Workforce Now some question was this one
for the the municipal ones like like the
primex and or was this for all arises we
we don't have a clear awareness of who
doesn't get their claims data from the
contract my understanding was yeah that
that this legislation was being driven
uh by um when that does Municipal which
is prime
X okay but thank
you
okay yeah that's so for self-funded uh
the companies in multiple States still
we monitor it or how does it
work it depends there are large group
plans that may operate in multiple
States um our chis is cus cus bace cus
space yeah we have a lot yeah so it's um
all plans CEST in New Hampshire we are
already collecting that data for fully
insured plans which it could include um
a multi-state
employer if it's a self-funded plan the
only way we're getting that data is if
they have opted into our system and are
agreeing to voluntarily give us that
data and this is Bill is aim to give
them another incentive to opt in because
we can't require them
to
tins what what was it what were you
calling
this sorry yeah what you you you sound
like you use the word chins or something
chis chis yeah which chis that's the
database that's the datab right that's
the actual database I should know I was
the sponsor of it what is it New
Hampshire make sure we put the New
Hampshire because Massachusetts has a
Chia and everybody has a different
different variation New Hampshire chis
is New Hampshire Comprehensive Health
Information System right and I'd like to
point out too it's not just the claims
data that's part of the chis there's
other types of data that are included in
that and accordingly in our statute that
this bill aims to amend but the goal was
to to try to figure out how do because
it said you say well how much does a
procedure cost at a certain Hospital
well you have different factors you have
the doctor you have the hospital and
then you have the the special the
anesthesiologist so was trying to
collect all that data so we could really
truly analyze what certain Hospital
groups what what things were costing so
that you can and and you can go online
and see see choose choose which is the
best hospital then we had the outcomes
too we had we have the outcome report
which which is uh which can be a little
misleading because if a hospital doesn't
do a procedure as often as someone else
it's another different hospital and has
one bad case it it could it could throw
it into the bad outcome category but but
uh but at least at least you get an idea
of you know of of of what the hospitals
are going to cost you what it's going to
cost for a
procedure all right we set thank you
very much close the public hearing and
like I say the subcommittees for these
bills uh will be in two weeks